OKAY. GOOD MORNING, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION WILL NOW
COME TO ORDER. MORNING,
EVERYBODY. THERE ARE 28 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, HOWEVER, ITEM
NUMBER 20, AB 2845 BY SPEAKER
RIVAS HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. EDITION OF THE COMMITTEE
HAS PULLED, TWO ITEMS FOR
HEARING NEXT WEEK. ITEMS NUMBER
SIX, AB 1971 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OTIS. AND ITEM NUMBER 24, AB
2925 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. WE HAVE 13 BILLS ON
CONSENT TODAY. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
1790. ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 1851.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 1884. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 1905. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB 2458. ITEM NUMBER 11 AB
2134. ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 2229.
ITEM NUMBER 13 AB 2349. ITEM
NUMBER 14 AB 2326. ITEM NUMBER
16 AB 2407. ITEM NUMBER 18 AB
2608. ITEM NUMBER 22, AB 2887
AND ITEM NUMBER 25 AB 2987.
ADDITIONALLY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NGUYEN CARILLO HAS PULLED HER AB
2865, WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER 21
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO
PRESENT THIS MORNING, ALL
WITNESSES THIS MORNING ARE ASKED
TO LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO
THREE MINUTES EACH TO ENSURE THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
TODAY'S AGENDA IN A TIMELY
FASHION. WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM, BUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
TWO MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE, AND WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WITH THE FIRST BILL AS A
PREROGATIVE OF THE CHAIR. WE ARE
GOING TO GO SLIGHTLY OUT OF
ORDER, OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE
TREASURER, WHO'S TAKING TIME OUT
OF HER BUSY DAY TO BE HERE TO
TESTIFY. AND WE WILL BE HEARING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY'S
BILL. IT'S NUMBER ITEM NUMBER 23
AB 2901. IT'S YES. WELL, OH, AND
WE HAVE A QUORUM BECAUSE WE HAVE
A SPECIAL GUEST STAR TODAY,
SENATOR LIMÓN IS FILLING IN FOR
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS,
GRATEFUL FOR YOU BEING HERE,
MADAM, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. NEWMAN.
HERE. NEWMAN HERE. OKUBO.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ HERE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. LIMÓN. LIMÓN. HERE.
WILK PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AGAR. CURRY.
WELCOME. YOU NOT ONLY HAVE A
QUORUM, YOU HAVE A GUEST STAR
WITH. I KNOW I LOVE MY GUEST
STARS, SO PLEASE PROCEED. ALL OF
THEM. READY, GOOD MORNING,
SENATORS. UNDER CURRENT STATE
LAW, EDUCATORS CANNOT EARN ANY
PAID PREGNANCY LEAVE. ONLY AFTER
THEY HAVE USED ALL THEIR SICK
AND SICK LEAVE. ARE EDUCATORS
ABLE TO RECEIVE DIFFERENTIAL PAY
WHEN THEY CANNOT WORK DUE TO
PREGNANCY RELATED DISABILITIES.
AND IN CASE YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH DIFFERENTIAL PAY, AFTER
EXHAUSTING ALL OF YOUR SICK
LEAVE, WHICH IS PART OF YOUR
COMPENSATION YOU RECEIVE FOR
YOUR JOB AS AN EDUCATOR, YOU GET
TO PAY FOR YOUR SUBSTITUTE OUT
OF YOUR NORMAL PAYCHECK.
EDUCATORS ARE LEFT WITH A
DECISION TO EITHER SCHEDULE
PREGNANCIES BASED ON THE SCHOOL
CALENDAR, OR TO TRY TO GET BY
WITH LESS PAY. FOR ANY OF YOU
WHO ARE PARENTS, I'M SURE YOU
KNOW HOW WELL SCHEDULING
PREGNANCIES WORK IN REAL LIFE.
THIS STANDARD IS UNACCEPTABLE IN
A WORLD WHERE WE ARE TRYING TO
EVOLVE IN OUR TREATMENT OF OUR
WORKERS. BUT SINCE THIS
LEGISLATION WAS LAST PROPOSED,
WE ARE NOW HAVE PROOF THAT THE
REAL WORLD IMPLICATION IS
INEQUITY FOR WOMEN IN THEIR
RETIREMENT. DATA FROM CALSTRS
SHOWS THAT WOMEN WILL RECEIVE
ALMOST $100,000 LESS IN
RETIREMENT BENEFITS THAN THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS. IN A
PROFESSION WHERE 70% ARE WOMEN.
THAT IS SHOCKING AND
UNACCEPTABLE. IT IS SYSTEMIC
SEXISM, AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
FIX IT. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT FOR
ME. WITH ME TODAY IS CALIFORNIA
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA AND
ERIKA JONES, THE SECRETARY
TREASURER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM TREASURER.
MISS JONES, WELCOME. LOVE TO
HAVE YOU AT THE TABLE HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, FOR
CARRYING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. MY MOTHER WAS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL ART TEACHER FOR 20 YEARS,
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
TEACHER SHORTAGE AS WELL AS THE
FACT THAT TEACHERS GET PAID
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS. AND AS WE
ARE, WORKING ON THIS BILL, WE
HAVE MANY YOUNG WOMEN WHO WANT
TO HAVE A FAMILY, BUT FOR THEIR
CONCERN ABOUT TAKING SICK LEAVE
OR NOT GETTING PAID, HAVING TO
PAY FOR SUBSTITUTES OUT OF THEIR
OWN POCKET, AND THEN OTHER WOMEN
WHO HAVE HAD BABIES AND TRYING
TO SCHEDULE THEM SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE IT DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS. AND IT JUST IS NEVER
EASY, I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
CALSTRS, AND WHEN AN EDUCATOR
RETIRES, CALSTRS CONVERTS UNUSED
SICK LEAVE TO ADDITIONAL SERVICE
CREDIT. HOWEVER, FOR THESE
UNFORTUNATE, WOMEN WHO HAVE TO
USE ALL OF THEIR SICK LEAVE,
THEY ACTUALLY GET PENALIZED WHEN
THEY RETIRE. SO THIS IMPORTANT
BILL WILL KEEP RETAIN MORE
TEACHERS, ENCOURAGE THEM TO NOT
ONLY STAY IN THE PROFESSION, BUT
ALSO START THEIR OWN FAMILIES
WITHOUT HAVING TO BE PENALIZED.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MISS JONES. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS ERIKA JONES.
I'M A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER, AND
I SERVE AS THE SECRETARY
TREASURER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING 310,000 EDUCATORS
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
FOR ME, AB 2901 IS DEEPLY
PERSONAL, IN AUGUST, I GAVE
BIRTH TO MY FIRST CHILD,
JOSEPHINE, WHO WAS ACTUALLY IN
THE BACK RIGHT NOW, AND IT'S
BEEN AN AMAZING TIME JUST
WATCHING HER GROW AND LEARNING
WITH HER. AND, YOU KNOW, ALL THE
THINGS FROM LEARNING TO CRAWL TO
NOW SHE'S ALMOST TRYING TO WALK,
AND IT'S JUST REALLY
DISHEARTENING THAT TEACHERS HAVE
ABSOLUTELY ZERO PAID PREGNANCY
LEAVE. THIS MEANS MOMS LIKE ME
HAVE HAD TO USE UP ALL OF OUR
SICK LEAVE, AND THEN WE CAN'T
EVEN TAKE TIME OFF IF WE GET
SICK OR IF OUR CHILDREN GET SICK
AFTER BIRTH. THE DECISION TO
HAVE CHILDREN IS REALLY NOT AN
ILLNESS. OUR MEMBERSHIP HAS BEEN
ENERGIZED BY THE ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER'S LEADERSHIP.
MORE THAN 15,000 HAVE SIGNED OUR
ONLINE PETITION TO FINALLY
ESTABLISH PAID PREGNANCY LEAVE
FOR OUR EDUCATORS, AND MANY HAVE
SHARED WITH ME THAT THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE PART OF SOMETHING
THAT IS HISTORIC AND MAKING A
REAL DIFFERENCE. I'VE BEEN IN
LUNCHROOMS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
WHERE BASICALLY MY COLLEAGUES
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ONE
EITHER TIMING BIRTHS, WHICH THAT
DIDN'T REALLY WORK OUT FOR ME. I
TIMED IT FOR TEN YEARS AGO, AND
IT HAPPENED THIS PAST AUGUST AND
OR REALLY TRYING TO JUDGE, CAN
WE ACTUALLY AFFORD NOT TO HAVE
PAY AND BUILD OUR FAMILY? SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
THAT WE KIND OF SHOW THAT THE
STATE CARES ABOUT THE STRUGGLES
OF TEACHERS THAT WE'RE FACING IN
THE CLASSROOM, AND THAT THEY'RE
THINKING CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW TO
HELP US. OUR STATE IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN TEACHERS IN MIDST OF A
SHORTAGE. AND 70% OF OUR TEACHER
WORKFORCE IS WOMEN. THE TIME IS
NOW TO PROVIDE TEACHERS WITH THE
DIGNITY TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
THEIR FAMILIES WITHOUT THE ADDED
STRESS OF SACRIFICING SICK DAYS
AND LOWER PAY. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL 2901.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE OTHERS PRESENT WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? PLEASE COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. JENNIFER
BAKER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA. RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND PROUD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. JESSICA
MARQUEZ, ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTEND OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND AND
PROUD SUPPORT AND ALSO AS A
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, ANY CHILD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, PROUD CO-SPONSORS
OR SPONSORS. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. ORTEZ WITH CHILDREN NOW
FOOD EMPOWERMENT PROJECT FRIENDS
COMMITTEE OF THE LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA HUMAN IMPACT PARTNERS
LÀ ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY,
LA BEST BABIES NETWORK, NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN FOR LOS
ANGELES, ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION, OUR FAMILY COALITION,
PARENT VOICES, SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BREASTFEEDING COALITION, AND
WORK SAFE AND YOU'RE A VERY BUSY
PERSON. THANK YOU. MARTHA
ZARAGOZA DIAZ, REPRESENTING THE
DELTA KAPPA GAMMA, CALIFORNIA,
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. YVONNE FERNANDEZ,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, PRISCILLA.
KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BELLA
KERN HERE ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO. UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
PETER ELLIOTT, CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHRIS MYERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ANNA
MATTHEWS, ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ROBLESS WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SARAH DIAZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WILK ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO IN SUPPORT ARE
THE CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILY
COALITION, THE ASIAN LAW
ALLIANCE, BREASTFEED, LA, THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION, CARING ACROSS
GENERATIONS, CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION, AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, CENTER
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS, CHILD CARE
LAW CENTER, CITIZENS FOR CHOICE,
ELECTRIC UNIVERSE, AND EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. SECOND BUSIEST
PERSON HERE. THANK YOU SIR.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. TONY
THURMOND, STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION, ON BEHALF
OF 6 MILLION STUDENTS, HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF EDUCATORS PROUD
TO BE A SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU TO YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. OKAY, LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO POSITION, DOES ANYBODY
HERE LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD BEFORE THE LEAD
WITNESSES AND YOU MAY COME TO
THE TABLE. Ở, PLEASE COME TO THE
TABLE. WE'LL DUKE IT OUT. DO WE
HAVE TWO? WE HAVE TWO LEAD
WITNESSES. PLEASE COME UP.
JEREMIAH'S HERE TO KEEP THE
PEACE. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ESQUIVEL AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS. WE HAVE THE
UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE INTENT OF
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL. SO WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AND YOUR
OFFICE ON THIS. OUR OUR, OUR
POSITION AND OUR CONCERNS REALLY
ARISE AROUND AND THE MULTIPLE
EXISTING LAWS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE. AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DID A GREAT JOB WITH
OUTLINING THE SIX DIFFERENT,
POLICIES THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN
TAKE WHEN IT COMES TO PREGNANCY,
DISABILITY, LEAVE, WHEN IT COMES
TO WHAT'S EXISTING LAW RIGHT NOW
, SHOULD SOMEONE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE CALIFORNIA PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE THAT PROVIDES
ABOUT 17 WEEKS ON AND THAT WILL
CONCURRENTLY RUN WITH THE FMLA,
WHEN YOU ADD THAT A TEACHER CAN
PRETTY MUCH TAKE SEPTEMBER TO
DECEMBER OFF WITH 2901, THAT
ADDS UP TO AN ADDITIONAL 14
WEEKS PAID LEAVE, OR WOULD ADD
UP TO 14 WEEKS OF LEAVE. AND
THAT COULD MEAN THAT A TEACHER
WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER AND JUNE OFF. AND SO
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS, AN APPROPRIATE TIME AND
SPACE FOR, FOR TEACHERS TO BE
ABLE TO, TAKE LEAVE AND PROVIDE
BABY BOND, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WE'RE THIS CAN EXACERBATE THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY ONE OF
THE WITNESSES. AND SO BEING ABLE
TO GET CREDENTIALED
CREDENTIALING TEACHERS FOR THAT
TIME LENGTH WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT. AND ANOTHER CHALLENGE
THAT WE SEE, BECAUSE KASBO DOES
REPRESENT SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICERS, WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS ALSO AN UNMANNED,
THIS IS A MANDATED COST, WE WANT
TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
IS, TAGGED AT, YOU KNOW, TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND WITHOUT
SOME FUNDING BEING PROVIDED FOR
THOSE PURPOSES. WE HAVE A GREAT
FISCAL CONCERN WITH THAT. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE THAT. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS, DOROTHY JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF AXA, THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, ALL ALIGN MOST
OF MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM KASBO. IT IS REALLY THE
FISCAL CONCERN WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL, AS WELL AS THE MULTIPLE
LAYERS OF EXISTING LEAVE. AND I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS THE
ONLY TYPE OF LEAVE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE
USE OF SICK LEAVE IS FULLY PAID.
THERE'S NO LIMIT ON HOW MANY
TIMES IT MAY BE TAKEN. IN
ADDITION TO NO SERVICE DATE ARE
REQUIRED BEFORE THIS LEAVE MAY
BE TAKEN. SO WHILE WE FULLY
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THIS MEASURE, AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE EMPLOYEES BOTH
CLASSIFIED AND TEACHING
POSITIONS HAVE SUPPORTS IN PLACE
WHEN THEY BRING A NEW FAMILY
MEMBER INTO THEIR FAMILY,
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH ADOPTION,
BIRTH, OR THERE'S OTHER
DISABILITY FOR PREGNANCY RELATED
ISSUES. UNFORTUNATELY, AGAIN,
THIS FISCAL IMPACT, WHICH I
BELIEVE WAS TAGGED IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
IS STILL A REMAINING CONCERN WE
HAVE YET TO ADDRESS. SO FOR
THESE REASONS, AXA IS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED, I
APPRECIATE THAT. ARE THERE
OTHERS HERE? I'D LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. LET'S SEE. NONE SO FAR.
LET US COME BACK. OH. I'M SORRY.
PLEASE JUST DO A SUPPORT. SURE.
TIFFANY, MOCK WITH CFT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, MISS MARTIN, AGAIN,
ANY ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION
WOULD LIKE TO GET ON THE RECORD,
NO. LET'S COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR LIMÓN, THE NEW
MEMBER, YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I'M GOING TO TAKE A WILD GUESS
THAT I MAY BE THE ONE ON THE
DAIS THAT HAS MOST RECENTLY, HAD
A CHILD, I COULD BE WRONG. THAT
WE KNOW OF. YES, THAT WE KNOW
THAT'S AN OLD JOKE. IT'S SO. SO
YOU KNOW, I THINK THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT THE
POLICY DISCUSSION THAT THIS BILL
BRINGS FORWARD, AND WHO
BARRETT'S WHO WHO, YOU KNOW, WHO
BEARS THE TAX, ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE, I THINK UP
UNTIL NOW, IT HAS BEEN WOMEN WHO
SERVE AS EDUCATORS IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS. I HEAR THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS, AND I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT LEAVE
POLICIES, BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A POLICY
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS AND IN
TERMS OF HOW TO FIX IT, I THINK
IN 2024, WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT, FOR THE
WOMAN WHO HAS THE CHILD TO BE
THE ONE THAT HAS TO TAKE, YOU
KNOW, HER, HER SICK LEAVE, I
THINK IS, THERE'S JUST AN IT'S A
TAX. IT IS A TAX ON AN
INDIVIDUAL. AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND, WHERE THAT IS
PLACED. AND SO I AM SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL I THINK IS A NEEDED
CONVERSATION. AND THANK YOU TO
OUR TREASURER, TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FOR ALSO BEING
CHAMPIONS FOR THIS, BUT
NONETHELESS, I THINK THAT, FOR
DECADES, THE COSTS THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HAVE BEEN SHIFTED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL WOMAN AND TO
WOMEN AS A WHOLE. SO THE FACT
THAT NOW WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SHIFTING
THOSE THOSE COSTS TO A BROADER
SYSTEM IS A NEEDED CONVERSATION.
BUT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S A
HARD ONE. AND CERTAINLY HAVING
SERVED ON A SCHOOL BOARD, I KNOW
IT WILL BE A HARD ONE. AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
POLICIES, BUT IT IS NEEDED. IT
IS 2024, AND WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE MOVE FROM THE WOMAN
BEING THE ONE WHO BEARS THAT
COST TO, YOU KNOW, UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS IS PART OF OUR SYSTEM.
AND SO WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD.
SO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS, MEMBERS. FOR THE
AUTHOR AT LEAST TO START, TO
THAT POINT ABOUT OVERLAPPING
POLICIES AND AMBIGUITY AROUND
IT. YOU KNOW, THERE'S CLEARLY
SOME NEED TO SIMPLIFY OR RENDER
CLEAR, HOW TO THINK ABOUT THAT
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. I
THINK THERE'S SOME TRUTH.
THERE'S TRUTH TO THAT. I MEAN,
THERE ARE SOME OVERLAPPING, BUT
THERE'S SOME THINGS. FOR
INSTANCE, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A
FMLA, IT'S THAT LEAVES UNPAID.
SO YOU MIGHT HAVE FMLA, BUT IT'S
UNPAID. AND SO IT'S JUST I THINK
THERE ARE POLICIES THAT KIND OF
CROSS OVER. BUT I THINK WE'RE ON
THE TRACK TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD. WE CONTINUE
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS
QUESTIONS ABOUT, CLARIFYING IF
THE PAID PREGNANCY LEAVE FOR
PART TIME EDUCATORS AND FACULTY
WILL MATCH THEIR PART TIME
STATUS. SO THERE'S THINGS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT TO US TO GET,
WOMEN, BACK ON TRACK. AND IT'S
JUST BEEN SO UNFAIR. AND AS YOU
CAN SEE, IS THAT WE HAVE PLENTY
OF WOMEN IN EDUCATORS HERE IN
THE ROOM THAT HAVE BEEN THERE,
DONE THAT, AND DON'T WANT THIS
TO GO BACK ON TO SOME OF OUR
YOUNGER TEACHERS AND MAKE SURE
WE KEEP PEOPLE AS, TEACHING IN
OUR SCHOOLS. I MEAN, THEY'RE
LEAVING BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE THEIR FAMILY. AND THEN IF
THEY DO COME BACK, THEY COULD BE
UP TO $100,000 OF LOST
RETIREMENT. AND I THINK MISS MOY
MADE IT PERFECTLY CLEAR THAT THE
DATA THAT THEY'VE COLLECTED. HOW
FAIR IS THIS? SO SORRY. I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
SO TO MISS JOHNSON'S POINT AND
MISS WESTERVELT, I MEAN, THIS
IS, THERE'S A SUBSTANTIAL FISCAL
IMPACT HERE, RIGHT? SO THAT'S
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A MATTER
FOR ANOTHER COMMITTEE, PROBABLY
APPROPRIATIONS. I SENSE A LITTLE
BIT OF, I GUESS, RETICENCE ON
BOTH OF YOUR PARTS. I MEAN, I
THINK YOU'D AGREE THERE IS THERE
IS A WORKFORCE CHALLENGE. AND WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT ONLY, SORT OF HONORING THE
PROFESSION AND MAKING IT
ATTRACTIVE PROFESSION, BUT ALSO
NOT PENALIZING THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY IN IT. SO, I MEAN,
ASSUMING THAT THE STATE WOULD
MAKE GOOD ON ITS OBLIGATION TO
FUND THESE SORTS OF MANDATES,
WHAT OTHER PROBLEMS MIGHT YOU
HAVE WITH THE WITH THE MEASURE
OR WITH THAT? WOULD THAT ADDRESS
YOUR CONCERNS? WELL, OUR CONCERN
IS LARGELY FISCAL. I THINK IT'S
ALSO, YES, THAT VACANCY SOME OF
OUR EDUCATORS HAVE SHARED. IT'S
NOT ABOUT STUDENT LEARNING LOSS.
IT'S ABOUT BEHAVIORAL ISSUES.
WHEN YOU EVERY 30 DAYS YOU HAVE
A NEW SUBSTITUTE TEACHER COMING
INTO THE CLASSROOM, FOR
CLASSIFIED POSITIONS, IT'S OFTEN
HARD TO BACKFILL THOSE. AND THEN
OF COURSE, THERE'S RIGHT OF
RETURN. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE POSITIONS ARE AVAILABLE.
SO THEN YOU HAVE VACANCIES AND
THEN THOSE THOSE HOURS, THOSE
SHIFTS ARE SHARED ON A SMALLER
SET OF SHOULDERS TO BEAR THAT
BURDEN. SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CURRENT WORKFORCE WHO
DOES REMAIN IN THEIR POSITIONS
AND THEY'RE NOT OUT ON LEAVE,
THEY'RE NOT ALSO BURNT OUT AND
WANTING TO LEAVE THE PROFESSION
BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY AREN'T
ENOUGH HANDS TO GO AROUND TO
CARRY THE WORKLOAD. I APPRECIATE
THAT, ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE WITNESSES? I THINK WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS A TASK
FORCE THAT WAS BEING FORCED. AND
I THINK THAT, AGAIN, THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DID A GREAT
JOB WITH OUTLINING THAT AND NOT
SURE WHETHER ANY ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS OR ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT TASK
FORCE ON JUST PAID LEAVE WERE OR
ARE BEING CONSIDERED. AND SO WE
THINK THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ON THE ON A BROADER
SCALE, NOT JUST WITHIN, PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN EDUCATION OR, WOMEN
THAT ARE IN EDUCATION, BUT
CALIFORNIA, I WOULDN'T DISAGREE
WITH AT ALL. BUT I THINK TO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARRETT CURRY'S
POINT, THIS IS THERE'S AN
URGENCY HERE THAT NEEDS
ADDRESSING. CORRECT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. YEAH. FAIR
ENOUGH. ANYTHING ELSE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? YES. TREASURER. ADD
THAT, WE KNOW AROUND THE STATE,
THERE ARE MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE DECLINING, DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. AND SO OUR NEXT
GENERATION, RIGHT, OUR, OUR,
NEXT GENERATION IS NOT HAVING
KIDS. SOME OF THEM, BUT THE ONES
THAT WANT TO ARE GETTING
PENALIZED OR THEY HAVE TO THINK
TWICE ABOUT HAVING THEIR OWN
FAMILY. SO THIS IS LIKE ON SO
MANY LEVELS. I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COST HERE, BUT
LOOK AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE HAVING DIFFICULTIES
BALANCING. MANY OF THE SCHOOLS
ARE FACING, YOU KNOW, DECISIONS
ON WHETHER TO SHUT DOWN, WHICH
MEANS THAT MORE TEACHERS ARE
GOING TO GET LAID OFF AND SO ON
TOP OF THAT, NOW YOU'RE ALSO
PENALIZING THE TEACHERS THAT
WANT TO STAY. SO I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT ONLY ONE OR THE OTHER, BUT,
YOU KNOW, AS WE'RE FACING THE
ISSUE ABOUT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT, WE SHOULD BE
INCENTIVIZING AND MAYBE
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BALANCE
OUT EVENTUALLY. I APPRECIATE
THAT, LAST CHANCE FOR COLLEAGUES
SEEING NONE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, AB 2901 WILL FINALLY
END THE DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICE
OF GIVING EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY WHO
ARE PREGNANT NO CHOICE BUT TO
DEPLETE THEIR SICK LEAVE A
BENEFIT THAT DIRECTLY AFFECTS
THEIR COMPENSATION NOW AND THE
RETIREMENT LEAVE AT A TIME WHEN
TEACHERS ARE SO STRESSED THAT
THEY'RE LEAVING THE PROFESSION
AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
CHOOSING DIFFERENT CAREERS, WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
HELP RECRUIT AND RETAIN
EDUCATORS. IT IS THE TIME WE
STOP CHARGING WOMEN $100,000 A
YEAR TO CARE FOR THEIR CHILD
UNTIL THEY RETURN TO CARE FOR
OURS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION? A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LIMÓN, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. FALL. ADAM 23 AB 2901
AGUIAR-CURRY. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS THE SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
OCHOA. CORTEZ CORTESE. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. LIMON LIMON.
AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE ALL
RIGHT THEN. MANAGER CURRENTLY
HAS FOUR VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, TREASURER MÀ. THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES, NOW, RETURNING TO
THE AGENDA, BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
ORDER, FIRST UP AND GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE IS AB 1855
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MR. CHAIR,
WOULD YOU MIND DOING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHILE WHILE WE'RE
SWITCHING OUT? DON'T MIND AT
ALL, MR. SHADOW CHAIR. SO, MADAM
KANSEN, IF YOU COULD, PLEASE, DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
WILK MOVE. WILK MOVES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IF WE COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MADAM
CONSULTANT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. IO CHO
BOGUE. CORTESE. CORTESE. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ LIMON. LEMON.
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. CONSENT CALENDAR
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW, WE WILL PROCEED,
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB
1855, ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMBLER.
WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND SENATORS.
STUDENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR STUDENT
BODY ASSOCIATION WITHOUT THREAT
TO SAFETY, PRIVACY OR
ACCESSIBILITY. AB 1855 WILL
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATIONS DURING THE COVID 19
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY, AUDIO
AND VIDEO TELECONFERENCING WAS
SUCCESSFULLY USED TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION AND TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CIVIL
SERVANTS AND THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER, CURRENT PROVISIONS OF
THE BROWN ACT REQUIRE MEMBERS OF
A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
PARTICIPATE IN MEETINGS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY BY
TELECONFERENCING FOR NO MORE
THAN 20% OF THE REGULAR MEETINGS
. THIS IS A BARRIER FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE DISABLED, WHO HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
OR ARE OTHERWISE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEETINGS IN
PERSON. AB 1855 PROTECTS PUBLIC
ACCESS AND ALLOWS AN ELIGIBLE
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A STUDENT
ORGANIZATION TO USE ALTERNATE
TELECONFERENCING PROVISIONS IF
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND ADOPTED BY THE
ELIGIBLE BODY, IT IS TIME FOR US
TO UPDATE THE ACT TO REFLECT
MODERN TIMES AND NEW CHALLENGES
FACED BY OUR STUDENTS. TESTING
FLYING IN SUPPORT OF AB 1855 IS
MIKAELA HUTCHINSON, A STUDENT
PARENT AND RECENT GRADUATE OF
MIRACOSTA COLLEGE AND LISA
BAKER, A STUDENT PARENT AT
MENDOCINO COLLEGE. MISS
HUTCHINSON, MISS BAKER, WELCOME.
EITHER OF YOU MAY PROCEED YOUR
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS LISA BAKER.
I AM A STUDENT PARENT AT
MENDOCINO COLLEGE AND A REGIONAL
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR WITH THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WHERE I
REPRESENT THE SEVEN NORTHERNMOST
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE STATE,
I ALSO JUST COMPLETED MY SECOND
TERM AS THE ASSOCIATE STUDENT
PRESIDENT AT MY SCHOOL, WHERE I
REBOOTED OUR STUDENT GOVERNMENT
POST PANDEMIC AND SAT ON
MULTIPLE COLLEGE COMMITTEES
VIRTUALLY. I AM PROUD TO HAVE
SPENT THE PAST FEW YEARS EARNING
THREE DEGREES AND GETTING DEEPLY
IMMERSED IN STUDENT
REPRESENTATION, BUT IT HAS BEEN
EXPONENTIALLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
I HAVE ALSO BEEN RAISING A
FAMILY. MY KIDS ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY AS AN EXAMPLE, AS A
STUDENT, PARENT, ATTENDING
MEETINGS IN PERSON IS
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH FROM UC
DAVIS, NEARLY ONE OUT OF TEN
STUDENTS IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHO APPLIED FOR FINANCIAL AID
ARE STUDENT PARENTS. WE FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND HAVE
SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT OTHER
STUDENTS DON'T NECESSARILY FACE,
AND WE MUST ENSURE WE ARE IN ALL
ROOMS WHERE DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE. AS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM A
RURAL AREA, I MAKE SACRIFICES TO
GET TO THE PLACES WHERE VOICES
LIKE MINE CAN BE HEARD.
CONSIDERING AN INSTALLMENT ON
ĐÃ
CONSIDERING IT AN INSTALLMENT ON
A BRIGHTER FUTURE, I SOMETIMES
GIVE UP TIME WITH MY FAMILY,
WITH MY SCHOOLWORK, I LOSE
SLEEP, I EXPEND RESOURCES BEYOND
WHAT CAN BE REIMBURSED MY HOUSE
IS 45 MINUTES FROM MY CAMPUS. MY
EFFORTS TO REACH STUDENT SENATE
MEETINGS AND OTHER ADVOCACY
EVENTS ARE USUALLY BOOKENDED BY
TWO HOUR DRIVES TO AND FROM
SACRAMENTO. SOMETIMES MY FAMILY
NEEDS ME AT HOME, THOUGH, AND
CAMPUS ISN'T ALWAYS A VIABLE
MEETING SPOT IN THESE SCENARIOS,
LIKE WHEN COVID WENT THROUGH MY
HOUSE OVER THE WINTER, I RELY ON
BROWN ACT ACCOMMODATIONS TO
ENSURE MY VOTE, BUT THAT COMES
AT AN UNCOMFORTABLE PRICE. I
HAVE TO DISCLOSE THE ADDRESS
WHERE MY MINOR CHILDREN CAN BE
FOUND. MOST PARENTS ARE
UNWILLING TO TAKE RISKS
REGARDING THEIR CHILDREN'S
SAFETY, EVEN SOME STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVES I WORK WITH ARE
MINORS WHO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THIS RISK. WHILE WE WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL STUDENT
BODY ORGANIZATIONS. AND EXCUSE
ME WHILE WE WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN A LOCAL STUDENT BODY
ORGANIZATION AND APPRECIATE THAT
WE CAN DO THAT FROM HOME, HAVING
TO POST OUR ADDRESS PUBLICLY IS
FRANKLY TERRIFYING. AB 1855
WOULD INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN
LOCAL STUDENT GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MISS HUTCHINSON.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MIKAELA
HUTCHINSON. I AM A FULL TIME
REMOTE STUDENT AT MIRACOSTA
COLLEGE IN SAN DIEGO, A STUDENT
PARENT AND A MILITARY SPOUSE.
BEFORE I SHARE MY STORY WITH YOU
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A
PART OF SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
STUDENT LEADERSHIP ADVISOR
DEBORAH KNOWLES TESTIMONY, WHICH
HAS INSPIRED ME TO SHARE MY OWN
STORY TODAY. SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE HAS APPROXIMATELY 17,000
STUDENTS. IT FLUCTUATES YEARLY,
BUT BETWEEN 40 AND 60% OF
STUDENTS ARE 100% ONLINE. ONLINE
STUDENTS DO NOT COME ON CAMPUS.
THIS SITUATION IS SIMILAR FOR
MOST CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE CURRENT BROWN ACT
MEANS THAT ONLINE STUDENTS ARE
OFTEN EXCLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATION IN STUDENT
LEADERSHIP. THEY MUST ATTEND IN
PERSON OR PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
WITH THEIR REMOTE ADDRESS POSTED
PUBLICLY. THIS MEANS THE PUBLIC
COULD COME IN THEIR HOME, JOIN
THE MEETING, AND USE THEIR
INTERNET ACCESS. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE RULES THAT PREVENT US FROM
GIVING OUT OUR STUDENT
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC.
DURING THE PANDEMIC, STUDENT
LEADERSHIP WAS ENGAGED.
ENVIRONMENT AND VIBRANT. IT WAS
INCLUSIVE. IT CROSSED ALL
SOCIAL, ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
AREAS. STUDENT LEADERSHIP IS A
PART OF STUDENT ENGAGEMENT, AND
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT ENGAGED
STUDENTS ARE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
STUDENTS. NOW THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS RESOLVED, THE BROWN ACT
WAIVERS HAVE BEEN LIFTED AND
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING TO BE
INCLUDED. NOW, HERE'S A PART OF
MY OWN EXPERIENCE. IN 2021, I
DECIDED TO RETURN TO COLLEGE
FULL TIME DESPITE HAVING TWO
VERY YOUNG CHILDREN, AGES THREE
AND ONE AT THE TIME, AND
RECEIVING LITTLE SUPPORT SINCE
OUR FAMILY LIVES VERY FAR AWAY
AND MY HUSBAND IS AN ACTIVE DUTY
MARINE, I CHOSE TO STUDY FULLY
ONLINE BECAUSE ATTENDING ON
CAMPUS CLASSES WAS NOT FEASIBLE
DUE TO MY CHILDREN'S UNEXPECTED
ILLNESSES, MY HUSBAND'S FIELD
OPERATIONS, AND MANY OTHER LIFE
CHALLENGES. BALANCING FULL TIME
PARENTHOOD WITH FULL TIME
STUDIES OFTEN ON MY OWN, WAS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. I
FREQUENTLY FELT DEPRESSED AND
SOUGHT CONNECTION WITH OTHERS.
MY INVOLVEMENT IN THE STUDENT
BODY, ESPECIALLY AFTER BEING
APPOINTED AS THE VP OF OUR
CONTINUING EDUCATION PROGRAM,
BECAME A CRUCIAL SOURCE OF
SOLACE AND PURPOSE FOR ME. I
THRIVE ON ADVOCACY AND I FELT I
WAS MAKING A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON MY CAMPUS. HOWEVER, I SOON
FACED A MAJOR OBSTACLE. I WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE MY PERSONAL
ADDRESS FOR PUBLIC RECORD, WHICH
CONFLICTED WITH THE SECURITY
PRINCIPLES INSTILLED IN ME AS A
MILITARY SPOUSE. DISCLOSING
PERSONAL INFORMATION POSES A
RISK TO MY HUSBAND, HIS FELLOW
SERVICE MEMBERS, AND US AS
FAMILY MEMBERS, AS WE NEVER KNOW
WHO IS WATCHING NOR THEIR
INTENT. THE REQUIREMENT MADE IT
CLEAR THAT CONTINUING MY ROLE IN
STUDENT BODY WAS NEITHER
ACCESSIBLE NOR FEASIBLE FOR
SOMEONE IN MY POSITION AS A
MILITARY SPOUSE AND REMOTE
STUDENT. I URGE LEGISLATORS TO
CONSIDER THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
FACED BY SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHEN VOTING ON
THIS LEGISLATION. AB 1855 WILL
EXPAND THE NECESSARY VOICES AND
ADVOCACY IN LOCAL STUDENT BODIES
WHILE PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS FROM
HAVING TO DISCLOSE PERSONAL
DETAILS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS
PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? SO PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOUR
POSITION. MISS MARK, WELCOME.
THANK YOU. TIFFANY. MARK CFT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, STEPHANIE GOLDMAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. DANNY MAE SANTIAGO,
ON BEHALF OF CALBRIGHT COLLEGE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
ANNA MATHEWS, ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE ALSO SEEING NONE, LET'S
COME BACK TO THE DESK,
COLLEAGUE. SINGULAR, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR? NO, I, I WILL SAY I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THERE'S CLEARLY A NEED TO
ADDRESS THE BROWN ACT ON A MORE,
KIND OF HOLISTIC BASIS AT SOME
POINT, MOVING FORWARD THAT SOME
OF THE LEGISLATURE TRULY NEEDS
TO DO, ESPECIALLY GIVEN CHANGES
IN TECHNOLOGY, BUT ALSO CHANGES
IN RELATIONSHIPS, AND HOW BEST
TO YOU KNOW, SORT OF COORDINATE
THESE, THESE SORTS OF OPEN
MEETINGS AND TECHNOLOGY EXISTS,
BUT OUR STATUTES HAVEN'T CAUGHT
UP. SO IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE, I THINK THIS MAKES
SENSE. I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT IT.
SENATOR LIMÓN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION? I'LL MAKE A
MOTION. SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
WANT TO ECHO THE TESTIMONY OF
OUR WITNESSES HERE TODAY WHO
SAID THAT ACCESSING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE
LEGISLATIVE BODIES IS IMPORTANT.
WE OFTENTIMES THINK OF THE BROWN
ACT AS THE PUBLIC'S WAY OF
ACCESSING THE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES, BUT WE OFTENTIMES DON'T
THINK ABOUT HOW THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THOSE SAID BODIES
AS WELL. AND SHOULD WE SHOULD BE
WORKING ON MAKING SURE THAT
STUDENT PARENTS AND DUAL
ENROLLED STUDENTS AND THOSE FROM
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE, AS WHEN WE HAVE
MORE PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN OUR
DEMOCRACY, WE ALL ARE WINNING.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR
MON. MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE
AB 1855 ARAMBULA. THE MOTION IS
DỰ PASS NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. GLASER.
GONZALEZ LIMÓN LIMÓN I WILK. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE CURRENTLY
HAS TWO VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU TO BOTH THE WITNESSES. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, NEXT, I
THINK WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
SORRY, I THOUGHT YOU I'M SURE
YOU THOUGHT YOU HAD HAD THE
INSIDE TRACK. MR. BERMAN,
WELCOME, YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
AB 2097, AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. MY APOLOGIES
TO MEMBER CARRILLO, MR. BUT WE
WILL BE QUICK, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS FROM SILICON VALLEY TO
BIOTECH BEACH, CALIFORNIA IS THE
UNDISPUTED CRADLE OF INNOVATION.
HOWEVER, FAR TOO MANY STUDENTS
GROW UP IN THE SHADOWS OF TECH
COMPANIES THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO ONE DAY WORK. THERE
THE REALITY IS, EVERY YEAR,
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING FURTHER
AND FURTHER BEHIND OTHER STATES
IN PROVIDING EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS.
LAST YEAR, CALIFORNIA WAS BEHIND
27 STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
REQUIRED EVERY HIGH SCHOOL TO AT
LEAST OFFER A COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSE. THIS YEAR, WE'RE BEHIND
31 OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THIS POLICY. MAYBE
2097 WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
ADOPT A PLAN TO ENSURE ALL HIGH
SCHOOLS OFFER AT LEAST ONE
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE BY THE
2028 2029 SCHOOL YEAR. THE BILL
PROVIDES A THOUGHTFUL, PHASED IN
APPROACH WITH ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY MEASURES TO ENSURE
SCHOOLS HAVE BOTH THE TIME AND
FLEXIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
SUCCESSFULLY. CALIFORNIA MUST DO
BETTER. IT'S TIME TO RESTORE
CALIFORNIA AS A LEADER AND TAKE
THE STEP TO ENSURE COMPUTER
SCIENCE FOR ALL. AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION WHO WAS
HERE EARLIER, BUT MAYBE HAD TO
GET BACK FOR MEETINGS FOR
PARTNERING WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT EFFORT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND I'M
JOINED TODAY BY MARY NICELY, THE
CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, AND
AMY PEZZONI, A HIGH SCHOOL
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHER, OKAY.
WELCOME, MISS NICELY. MISS,
WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST,
PLEASE PROCEED. I'LL GO FIRST.
IS THAT ON? WAS THAT ON OR OFF?
IS THAT ON? YOU ARE ON. HEAR ME?
GREAT. GOOD MORNING. MARY
NICELY, CHIEF DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, REPRESENTING STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
AND WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
2097. AND THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED, 55% OF
HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA DO
NOT OFFER ANY COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES, LAGGING BEHIND 31 OTHER
STATES. YET WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF COMPUTING JOBS IN THE
NATION, WITH SALARIES AVERAGING
OVER $150,000. WE ARE NOT GIVING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS TO THESE
JOBS IN THE STATE. THEY LIVE IN
THE BIRTHPLACE OF THE HIGH TECH
INDUSTRY. THIS NEEDS TO CHANGE.
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS MORE THAN
CODING. TECHNOLOGY PERMEATES,
PERMEATES OUR LIVES AND
COMMUNITY. COMPUTER SCIENCE IS
VALUABLE EVEN FOR THOSE NOT
PLANNING ON ENTERING THE TECH
INDUSTRY. WE SEE TECHNOLOGY
GROWING ACROSS EVERY INDUSTRY
AND AGRICULTURE, CONSTRUCTION,
HEALTH, ENTERTAINMENT, FASHION,
BANKING, ELECTIONS, ARTS, AND
MORE. THE RISE OF AI MAKES IT
EVEN MORE CRITICAL THAT WE
ADDRESS DIGITAL LITERACY AND
THAT COMPUTER SCIENCE IS AT THE
CORE, AT THAT OF DIGITAL
LITERACY FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR COMMUNITY IN GENERAL, IN
2018, CALIFORNIA ADOPTED
COMPUTER SCIENCE STANDARDS WITH
INTRODUCTORY STANDARDS FOR
GRADES 9 TO 12, DESIGNED TO BE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCESS SHOULD NOT BE
BASED ON ZIP CODE, RACE, OR
GENDER. CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DO NOT
RECEIVE COMPUTER SCIENCE
INSTRUCTION, AND THIS IS EVEN
MORE TRUE FOR PARTICULAR
POPULATIONS. IN CALIFORNIA,
BLACK AND LATINX STUDENTS ARE
FOUR TIMES LESS LIKELY THAN
THEIR WHITE AND ASIAN PEERS TO
HAVE AIPCS COURSES, AND ONLY 31%
OF AP CS TEST TAKERS ARE FEMALE.
SO CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
INVESTMENTS IN A PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR OUR EDUCATORS OVER
$20 MILLION IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. AND THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
$50 MILLION IN MATH AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSES TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
TEACHERS. SO WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO MOVE FORWARD
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AND
CATCH UP TO THE 31 OTHER STATES
THAT ARE FAR AHEAD OF US. AND I
AM PROUD TO REPRESENT CDE AND
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON AB 2097.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MISS PISONI. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE TODAY. MY
NAME IS AMY PEZZONI AND I'VE
BEEN A TEACHER IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR OVER TEN YEARS. MY
HOPE IS TO GIVE YOU INSIGHT INTO
MY CLASSROOM AND INTO THE
IMPORTANCE THAT COMPUTER SCIENCE
CAN OFFER CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
SITES LIKE MY PARENTS MADE ME
TAKE THIS CLASS. I DON'T KNOW
HOW I GOT IN THIS CLASS. I
DIDN'T BALLOT FOR IT. I'M ONLY
HERE UNTIL MY COUNSELOR CAN
SWITCH ME. THESE ARE THE FEW OF
THE ANSWERS THAT I GET TO THE
START OF THE YEAR. INTERVIEW
QUESTION LIKE, WHY DID YOU TAKE
THIS CLASS THESE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE NO INTENTION OF TAKING A
COMPUTER SCIENCE ELECTIVE COURSE
ARE SOME OF MY FAVORITE STUDENTS
. IN THE INTERVIEW ACTIVITY,
STUDENTS LIGHT UP WHEN THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
THEY ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT. THEY
TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
THEY TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
WORKING ON, AND THEY TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH. AS
I INTRODUCE EACH TOPIC IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE, I WEAVE THESE
PASSIONS INTO OUR CLASS. I OFFER
FUN FACTS ABOUT COMPUTER
SCIENCE. DID YOU KNOW THAT
MODERN CARS HAVE OVER 100
MILLION LINES OF CODE? I
ENCOURAGE THEM TO APPLY THE
SKILLS THEY ARE LEARNING TO
THEIR AREA OF INTEREST FOR THE
HTML PROJECT. WHAT ABOUT AN
HOMAGE TO YOUR CAT'S EYE FRAME
CONCEPTS IN THEIR AREA OF
INTEREST? WHAT IS A RECIPE BUT A
STRUCTURED ALGORITHM AND I HELP
THEM FIND CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
WHAT THEY ARE MOST INTERESTED IN
AND THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
SUPPORTS, ENHANCES, AND AIDS IT.
I LOVE THAT YOU WANT TO GO INTO
MEDICINE. SEE WHAT YOU CAN FIND
OUT ABOUT SURGICAL ROBOTS THAT
DOCTORS USE. AS MY STUDENTS
DISCOVER HOW MUCH MORE OF THEIR
CHOSEN WORLD OPENS UP TO THEM,
THEY BECOME SOME OF MY MOST
ENTHUSIASTIC STUDENTS. AND THESE
ARE THE STUDENTS THAT
INTRODUCTORY COMPUTER SCIENCE
MOST HELPS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THEY THINK COMPUTER SCIENCE
ISN'T FOR THEM. THEY THINK
THEY'RE NOT SMART ENOUGH, THAT
THEY WON'T SEE STUDENTS THAT
LOOK LIKE THEM IN THEIR CLASSES,
AND THAT IT DOESN'T CONNECT TO
THEIR INTERESTS. AB 2097 SHOWS
NONE OF THAT IS TRUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME, FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR CHOOSING
EDUCATION IN YOUR LEGISLATIVE
CAREERS. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS PRESENT WHO'D LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AND SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE? PLEASE DO SO. EMILY
PAPPAS, NIEMELA PAPPAS, AND
ASSOCIATES IN SUPPORT FOR
SALESFORCE AS WELL AS PAYPAL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. NICK BROKAW FROM MIKE
FROM SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF MICROSOFT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSE TORRES CASILLAS, ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET, AMAZON
GETAROUND, SALESFORCE, SNAP INC,
ZILLOW, PAYPAL, AND ZOOX ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CAITLIN ZHANG, ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CONNELLY WITH WHITMAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF KIRA
LEARNING, PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
THANK YOU, COURTNEY JENSEN, ON
BEHALF OF CODE.ORG IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PERRY, ON BEHALF OF COLLEGE
BOARD, ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, JOHN SWEENEY, ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. LET'S MOVE TO ANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE BACK TO THE DAIS,
MISS MAZZONI, I WISH YOU'D BEEN
MY TEACHER. I MIGHT HAVE
AMOUNTED TO SOMETHING. AND I
WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, GLAD IT'S
WITH THE BILL. AND SO YOUR
TESTIMONY SUPPORTS THE BROADER
ARGUMENT FOR HAVING COMPUTER
SCIENCE AS A REQUIRED PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA CURRICULUM. AND I
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SOME
BERMAN'S BEEN WORKING ON. I KNOW
THAT CODE.ORG HAS BEEN FULLY
BEHIND IT. SO GLAD TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TODAY. GLAD TO
SUPPORT THAT LARGER EFFORT.
SENATOR WILK, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO I'M A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE, BUT 20, 25 YEARS AGO
MOVED TO THE MIDWEST TO DO A
STARTUP COMPANY. THE STATE THAT
WE WERE IN, COMPUTER SCIENCE
REQUIRED EVERY STATE. THIS IS IN
1999. AND SO WE ARE SO FAR
BEHIND AND US BEING THE HUB OF
TECHNOLOGY, IT JUST IT BLOWS MY
MIND. WE COMMIT ALL THESE
RESOURCES TO THINGS THAT DON'T
MATTER, AND THEN WE DON'T FOCUS
ON WHAT IS WHAT DOES MATTER. SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT YOUR TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON THESE ISSUES AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY, AND
I WILL MOVE THE BILL. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT AS WELL, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, SIR? I JUST
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
EVERYBODY AND AGREE. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON MY ENTIRE EIGHT YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND I'LL BE HONEST,
I'M DISAPPOINTED AT THE LACK OF
PROGRESS I'VE MADE, BUT THE WORK
KEEPS GOING AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT EFFORT. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALL SUPPORT.
YEAH, WE ARE EQUALLY
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU. SO BUT BUT
WE'RE ROOTING FOR YOU. I'M
VOTING ON YOUR BILL IN TEN
MINUTES. IN ELECTIONS I AM GLAD
TO SUPPORT THIS. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. FINAL ITEM SEVEN AB 2097
BERMAN. MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN, I OCHOA BOGH
CORTESE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. LIMÓN
WILK I WILK I. THAT MEASURE NOW
HAS TWO VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ALL OF OUR MEMBERS. FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE WONDERING WHY
THE DAY IS SO EMPTY, WE HAVE
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES THAT THAT
MEET CONCURRENTLY, AND MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE ACTUALLY
CHAIRING OTHER COMMITTEES RIGHT
NOW. SO APOLOGIES TO EVERYBODY
WHO'S MADE THE TIME TO BE HERE,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, NOW I HAVE TO
GO AND PRESENT A BILL IN
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS. I'LL DO THIS
QUICK AND REYES OVER THERE.
OKAY. LET'S DO IT. YEAH OKAY, I
KNOW, I MEAN, YOU CAN GO. I'LL
MAKE SURE THAT I'M THERE IN
TIME. BY THE TIME, YOU KNOW,
YOUR OTHER BILL IS ON CONSENT.
OH, IS IT. OH. I'M SORRY. OH,
YOU'RE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
SOMEBODY. NO HE HAS THREE TOTAL
ONES. TOO MANY ARE I SEE, I
MISSED THIS SO. SO I'M STAYING
HERE WITH YOU, AB 2876. PLEASE
PROCEED. ÁP 2876 WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL K THROUGH 12 STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE PREPARED WITH
THE AI LITERACY SKILLS NECESSARY
TO COMPREHEND BASIC AI
PRINCIPLES AND APPLICATIONS,
RECOGNIZE WHEN AI IS EMPLOYED,
AND UNDERSTAND AI'S IMPLICATIONS
AND LIMITATIONS AND ETHICAL
CONSIDERATIONS. SPECIFICALLY,
THIS BILL DIRECTS THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
TO CONSIDER INCORPORATING AI
LITERACY CONTENT INTO THE MATH,
SCIENCE, AND HISTORY SOCIAL
SCIENCE CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS.
WHEN THOSE FRAMEWORKS ARE NEXT
REVISED. AS AI GROWS IN
POPULARITY AND GETS INTEGRATED
INTO MORE AND MORE ELEMENTS OF
SOCIETY, CHILDREN GROWING UP IN
TODAY'S DIGITAL WORLD NEED TO BE
BETTER EQUIPPED WHEN ANY THAN
ANY GENERATION BEFORE. TO
UNDERSTAND THESE PRINCIPLES.
THIS IS SORT OF TANGENTIALLY
RELATED TO THE LAST BILL I
PRESENTED. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
IS RONARC'H DELORME, POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. MR. LAMY,
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ROANOKE,
DELORME WITH CAL CHAMBER, THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 2876. I'LL
KEEP IT BRIEF BECAUSE I NOTED
THE ANALYSIS DOESN'T REFLECT ANY
OPPOSITION. BUT WE DO WANT TO
START BY THANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN FOR AUTHORING THIS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION. WE ALL
KNOW THAT AI IS AN UNDENIABLY
TRANSFORMATIVE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WILL HAVE WIDESPREAD IMPACT ON
VIRTUALLY ALL ASPECTS OF SOCIETY
AND OUR ECONOMY, PERHAPS MORE SO
THAN ANYTHING SINCE THE
INTERNET. IT PRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROMISE, FROM
LIFE SAVING ADVANCEMENTS IN
MEDICINE TO ADDRESSING ANY
NUMBER OF SOCIETAL CHALLENGES.
BUT IT CAN ALSO BE APPLIED IN
WAYS THAT ARE LESS DESIRABLE,
SUCH AS SPREADING
DISINFORMATION, UNFAIR.
FORTUNATELY, WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IN OUR COMMUNITIES,
OUR WORKPLACES OR GOVERNMENT,
WHICH CREATES ISSUES OF MISTRUST
OF THE TECHNOLOGY, UNDERMINING
ITS POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND
MAKING IT HARDER TO COMBAT ITS
CHALLENGES. OUR MEMBERS STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT AI LITERACY AND
MEDIA LITERACY ENCOMPASS
FUNDAMENTAL SKILLS THAT CHILDREN
NEED IF THEY ARE TO SUCCEED AS
CONSUMERS, VOTERS AND WORKERS IN
THE MODERN WORLD. AB 2876 TAKES
THE FIRST STEPS TO ENSURING THAT
AND WE ARE VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR
THE BILL. AGAIN, THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, ARE THERE OTHERS HERE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? WELCOME, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS. SAM NASH, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSE TORRES CASILLAS
WITH TECHNET AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, NAOMI PADRON, ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION HERE TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, BACK TO
THE DAIS. WELCOME, SENATOR JOE
BORG, I AM EQUALLY GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL, THIS IS PART
OF A LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT
LITERACY AND THE IMPACT OF
TECHNOLOGY ON OUR LIVES AND OUR
EDUCATION, THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
IN THIS SPACE, ANY OTHER
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY. SENATOR WILK MOVES THE
BILL, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, PLEASE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM. ALL
DONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM NINE AB 2876. BERMAN.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH
TOBAGI. CORTEZ. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
LIMÓN. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE THAT
MEASURE NOW HAS THREE VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, AND AGAIN, I
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO GO PRESENT
IN ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS, AND
HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE RELATIVELY
BRIEF. SENATOR BOGUE, I'M GOING
TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO YOU
AND AGAIN, APOLOGIES TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKE THEIR
WAY HERE, AND DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
OF US ON THE DAIS AT ANY GIVEN
TIME. I'LL BE BACK. GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME. MEMBER CARRILLO.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE. WHEN
YOU'RE READY, YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING, AB 2071. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY. BILL 2071.
AS SOME OF YOU MIGHT KNOW, I'M
AN IMMIGRANT, BILINGUAL SPEAKER,
AND A LIFELONG ENGLISH LEARNER.
I KNOW THE STRUGGLE OF LEARNING
A NEW LANGUAGE WHILE TRYING TO
SEEK AN EDUCATION. FOR A LONG
TIME IN CALIFORNIA, NATIVE OR
HOME LANGUAGES WERE SEEN AS
BARRIERS TO ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL SUCCESS. IN 2017,
THE STATE TOOK A TRANSMITTER
STEP FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS WHEN
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION
UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED THE
CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARNER
ROADMAP POLICY. THE ROADMAP SET
FORTH NEW LEARNING PRINCIPLES
WHICH VIEW STUDENTS NATIVE
LANGUAGES AS AN ASSET, BUT
DESPITE THIS POLICY, THERE
REMAIN GAPS IN ACHIEVEMENT FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS. WHILE THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS OF ROADMAP,
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION PRODUCED
SOME BRIGHT SPOTS DUE TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANTS,
THAT PROGRAM ALONE WAS NOT
ENOUGH TO MOVE THE NEEDLE FOR
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC AND BROAD CHANGE
ACROSS THE STATE. AB 2071 WILL
SUBJECT THE APPROPRIATION
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATIONS,
PROVIDE NO MORE THAN 12 SEPARATE
ONE TIME GRANTS TO LEAS TO
IMPLEMENT THE ENGLISH LEARNER
ROADMAP PROGRAM OVER THREE
YEARS. THOSE LEAGUES WITH THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS WILL BE PRIORITIZED
ALONG WITH THOSE WITH THE LOWEST
NUMBERS OF ELLS, TO ENSURE NO
ONE IS LEFT OUT WITH REGARD TO
RECIPIENTS, THE BILL ENSURES
THERE IS A BALANCE OF URBAN AND
RURAL SCHOOLS SERVED. AS A
PARENT, I ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF PLAYING AN ACTIVE ROLE
IN MY CHILDREN'S EDUCATION,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
BRINGING PARENTS INTO THE FALL
OF THEIR CHILD'S UNIQUE ENGLISH
LEARNING JOURNEY. AB 2071 WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO CREATE AND ADOPT A
CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARNER
ROADMAP. PARENT TOOLKIT. THIS
TOOLKIT WOULD INCLUDE QUESTIONS
FOR PARENTS TO ASK THEIR
SCHOOLS, INCLUDING USE OF
DESCRIPTORS OF EACH PRINCIPAL OF
THE ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP. THE
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES GIVEN
TO PARENTS WILL BE IN THEIR
PRIMARY LANGUAGE, EQUIPPED WITH
INCENTIVE GRANTS AND WITH THE
HELP OF PARENT TOOLKIT LEAS AND
ENGLISH LEARNERS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE BETTER ABLE TO ENGAGE
AND BUILD GENERATIONAL SKILLS.
JOINING ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS IS DOCTOR
ELENA ESTARÁ. GÂY VICE
PRESIDENT, ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATION
SERVICES FOR THE PALMDALE SCHOOL
DISTRICT, AND MARTA HERNANDEZ,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU MY
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF AB 2071.
MY NAME IS ELENA ESTARÁ. I'M THE
PROUD ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
OF EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
PALMDALE SCHOOL DISTRICT. I AM
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF WHO
AM I REPRESENTING TODAY? WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD THE ENGLISH
LEARNER ROADMAP POLICY SINCE
2017, WHICH WAS APPROVED BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION, WE
HAVE YET TO ENSURE ITS FULL
IMPLEMENTATION STATEWIDE. THIS
IMPORTANT POLICY BECAME LOST IN
THE COMPLEXITY OF DEALING WITH
THE PANDEMIC FOR SO MANY OF OUR
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE, MY
DISTRICT INCLUDED. AS A RESULT,
WE DO NOT HAVE A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF HOW MANY DISTRICTS
HAVE EITHER FULLY OR PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED THE ENGLISH LEARNER
ROADMAP. MY DISTRICT BEGAN
IMPLEMENTING THE ROADMAP IN THE
FALL OF 2020. WE DEVELOPED OUR
ROADMAP BY COLLABORATING WITH
VARIOUS EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS AND
FOCUS GROUPS REPRESENTING OUR
DISTRICT. ALTHOUGH WE ARE
WORKING TOWARD FULL
IMPLEMENTATION, OUR PROGRESS HAS
BEEN SLOWED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
AND THE LACK OF RESOURCES SUCH
AS FUNDING AND SUBSTITUTES FOR
STAFF TRAINING. WE HAVE PROVIDED
AN OVERVIEW TO ALL PARTNERS,
INCLUDING PARENTS AND STAFF, BUT
MORE IN DEPTH TRAINING IS STILL
NEEDED. CABE BELIEVES FEW
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ENSURE THIS COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
IS ABLE TO GET FULLY
IMPLEMENTED, OR MAY HAVE
ABANDONED IMPLEMENTATION DURING
THE PANDEMIC, AND MAY NOT HAVE
GOTTEN BACK ON COURSE. THE
CURRENT FISCAL CLIMATE IS ALSO
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS
TO MAKE PROGRESS AS RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS AT
THE LEVEL THAT THEY NEED TO
SUCCEED HAS BECOME SCARCE. MANY
DISTRICTS NEED MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT TO
IMPLEMENT THE ENGLISH LEARNER
ROADMAP BY PROVIDING DEDICATED
RESOURCES, AS THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING PULLED IN
NUMEROUS DIRECTIONS. AS AB 2071
WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA IS
ACTIVELY IMPLEMENTING THE
ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP BY
PROVIDING NO MORE THAN EIGHT ONE
TIME GRANTS OF UP TO 1.5 MILLION
PER GRANT, AS WELL AS NO MORE
THAN FOUR ONE TIME GRANTS OF UP
TO $750,000 PER GRANT, SUBJECT
TO APPROPRIATE THÀNH. IN
ADDITION, IT WOULD TASK THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THÀNH
WITH THE CREATION OF A PARENT
TOOLKIT TO ALLOW BOTH PARENTS
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ENGLISH
LEARNER ROADMAP IS AND WHAT IT
MEANS TO THEIR CHILDREN'S
SUCCESS. PARENTS HAVE TO BE A
PART OF THIS PROCESS. PLEASE
SUPPORT THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARNERS BY
VOTING AYE ON AB 2071. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW ME
TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENGLISH LEARNERS,
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBER WILK.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. I'M MARTA HERNANDEZ,
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WITH 42
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN K-12
EDUCATION AS A BILINGUAL AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND A
COUNTY DISTRICT AND SITE
ADMINISTRATOR. CONCLUDING MY
EDUCATION CAREER AS ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR THE FILLMORE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
VENTURA COUNTY. I AM EXCITED TO
SEE AB 2071 MOVING FORWARD AND
GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO'S LEADERSHIP THIS BILL
COMES FROM THE FIELD AND
ADDRESSES THE VAST NEED TO SERVE
OUR 1.1 MILLION ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND SUPPORT OUR EDUCATORS ALONG
THE WAY. CALIFORNIA'S ENGLISH
LEARNER POLICY SEE THE ENGLISH
LEARNER ROADMAP IS A
COMPREHENSIVE, VISIONARY,
RESEARCH BASED POLICY THAT, BY
DESIGN, TOUCHES ALMOST ALL
ASPECTS OF SCHOOLING AND
REQUIRES THE INVOLVEMENT AND
ALIGNMENT OF MULTIPLE ROLES OF
TEACHERS, OF ADMINISTRATORS,
COUNSELORS, AND PARA-EDUCATORS,
AS WELL AS PARENTS AND ALL
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN A LOCAL
DISTRICT. IN TAKING A SHARED
RESPONSE ABILITY FOR ENGLISH
LEARNER EDUCATION. WHEN
IMPLEMENTED, THE ELL ROADMAP IS
POWERFUL AND CAN HAVE A REAL
IMPACT, BUT BECAUSE THE POLICY
CALLS FOR A PARADIGM SHIFT FROM
A DEFICIT ORIENTATION TO AN
ASSETS ORIENTATION, BECAUSE IT
CALLS FOR THE BUILDING OF
SYSTEMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT EFFECTIVE PRACTICES AND
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES DEEP
UNDERSTANDING AND CAPACITY. KẾT
ABOUT ENGLISH LEARNERS AND WHAT
THEY NEED TO THRIVE. IT IS A BIG
LIFT TO IMPLEMENT. THIS MEANS
THAT DISTRICTS ARE FACED WITH
THE POLICY KỲ TO UNDERSTAND A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY TO
IMPLEMENT, AND A NEW
RESPONSIBILITY AND ACCOUNTABLE
KẾT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN. SO THIS IS WHERE THE
GRANTS PROPOSED BY AB 2071 ARE
CRUCIAL. SCHOOL AND EDUCATORS
THAT NEED ASSISTANCE TO DEVELOP
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THAT
EFFECTIVELY SERVE THEIR ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND COMMUNITIES. THEY
NEED GUIDANCE, PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT AB 2071 WILL
PROVIDE. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME, AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS VERY CRITICAL,
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM 2100 SAM
NASHUA WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TIFFANY
MARK, ON BEHALF OF CFT, A UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. CARSON EADES, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, DEBORAH
SANDERS ON BEHALF OF CATALYST
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD MORNING,
CAROL GONZALEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
ESPINAS ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SARA, I JUST CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT RAQUEL MORALES ON BEHALF
OF TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT MARTHA
ZARAGOZA DÍAS ON BEHALF OF DELTA
KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT RACHEL BHAGWAT WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL NOW
CONTINUE WITH ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2071. SEEN
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS. I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM. I'M. I'M SAD
THAT IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE. I HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVE, THAT THE SCHOOLS
RECEIVE ON BEHALF OF OUR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS, WHAT IS THAT
NORMALLY BASED ON YOUR
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE, WHAT IS
THAT BEING ALLOCATED? WHAT KIND
OF SERVICES IS THAT CURRENTLY
BEING PROVIDED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? WHAT ARE SCHOOLS
USING THAT FUNDING FOR? BECAUSE
I, I WOULD ASSUME THAT THAT
WOULD BE, THAT WOULD BE USED FOR
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THESE TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS THAT ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AS WELL. I
THINK THAT, YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK, AND I THINK THAT,
DISTRICTS NEED A DISTRICT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO TARGET
THOSE FUNDS IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THE ROADMAP. AND SO
THOSE FUNDS, YES, ARE PERHAPS
SPENT ON SOME INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS, PERHAPS IT'S SPENT ON
SOME SERVICES FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS, BUT IT'S NOT DONE IN A
SYSTEMATIC, KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE, TARGETED WAY BY
ALIGNING TO THE FOUR PRINCIPLES
OF THE ELL ROADMAP. AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS TO HELP
DISTRICTS DEVELOP THAT PLAN AND
INVOLVE ALL STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED, ALL THOSE WHO ARE,
DEVELOPING, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
LCAP AND THEIR, YOU KNOW, THEIR,
THEIR SCHOOL SITE PLANS AND
TARGET IT TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS POLICY IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE FOUR PRINCIPLES OF THE
ROADMAP. SO BASICALLY, WE
HAVEN'T BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN
USING THAT EXTRA FUNDING FOR
ELLS IN THE PAST. WHAT HAS BEEN
I THINK IT'S BEEN ABOUT TEN
YEARS. IT'S BEEN, WE'VE BEEN THE
STATE HAS BEEN ALLOCATING THIS
FUNDING FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IN THE STATE. SO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT WE HAVEN'T
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN UTILIZING
THAT IN PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
DATA BASED, RESEARCH BASED,
ORIENTED, AS A STATE. I MEAN, WE
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED, I BELIEVE, 3
OR 4 TIMES IN ANALYZING ALL CAPS
OF DISTRICTS WITH THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE AND THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF ENGLISH LEARNERS.
AND, I HATE TO SAY THAT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR CAPS SOMETIMES
DO NOT HAVE ANY GOALS RELATED TO
ENGLISH LEARNERS, AND IF THEY
DO, THEY'RE VERY GENERAL AND NOT
SPECIFIC TO THE TYPOLOGY OF
ENGLISH LEARNERS. IN OTHER
WORDS, IT'S JUST GENERAL ENGLISH
LEARNERS WITHOUT CONCERN FOR THE
NEEDS OF NEWCOMERS AND THE NEEDS
OF LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNERS.
THE NEEDS OF, YOU KNOW,
REFUGEES, ETC. AND SO BY
ASSISTING DISTRICTS, YOU KNOW,
TO DEVELOP THESE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS, THESE DISTRICTS WILL
BECOME THE MODEL SO THAT IN THE
FUTURE THE OTHER DISTRICTS CAN
SAY, YOU KNOW, WHERE IS IT
HAPPENING? YOU KNOW, WHERE IS A
DISTRICT THAT'S TRULY
IMPLEMENTING THE ELL ROADMAP.
AND WE WILL HAVE BRIGHT SPOTS
FOR THEM, THE INTENTION IS THAT
THESE DISTRICTS WILL, YOU KNOW,
BECOME MODELS FOR OTHER
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. IT'S
ACTUALLY KIND OF DISAPPOINTING
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OUR KIDS HAVE NOT BEEN TARGETED
IN THE WAY THAT IT'S BEEN
INTENDED FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS,
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS. I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. YES, GOOD MORNING,
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION, ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE.
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION THAT IN
CONCERN THAT YOU'RE RAISING, AB
2071 IS REALLY MEANT TO BE A
CATALYST TO HELP US TO MOVE
FORWARD AND BE CREATIVE IN WAYS
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THAT
SUPPORT TO DISTRICTS. WE HAVE
SEEN SOME DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP, BUT WE
HAVE HAD SO MANY ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES AND DIVERSIONS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED WITH THE PANDEMIC
AND OTHER ISSUES IN THE STATE
THAT HAS CREATED A CHALLENGE. SO
WE SEE THAT PROVIDING THESE
INCENTIVE GRANTS TO HELP THE
DISTRICT TO MOVE FORWARD IS
GOING TO BE A TOOL. AND OUR HOPE
IS THAT IT IS THEN GOING TO
PROMOTE OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SKILLS THAT THEY NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD. SO SOMETIMES WE
HAVE TO GIVE OUR FRIENDS A
LITTLE BIT OF HELP, AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO
DO. YEAH. WELL, JUST FOR THE
RECORD, TEN YEARS IS A VERY LONG
TIME FOR US NOT TO HAVE A PLAN,
IN PLACE FOR THE STATE THAT
CATERS TO BOTH DATA RESEARCH
BASED PRACTICES AS WELL AS
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THAT END. SO I
WILL BE GRATEFUL TO SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD. AND WITH
THAT MEMBER CARILLO, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I'LL SIMPLY CLOSE
BY REQUEST YOUR AYE, VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM SECRETARY, WOULD YOU
CALL THE ROLE FOR ITEM TEN AB
2071, JUAN CARRILLO? THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATING COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
OKUBO A OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. GLASER.
GONZALEZ LIMÓN. WILK. ĐÃ. WILK.
I THANK YOU. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS? OKAY, WE'LL, WE'LL WAIT
.
SINCE IT'S A BUSY DAY, CAN WE
OPEN THE ROLL ON ARAMBULO? SINCE
I HAD TO STEP OUT TO OPEN. I
KNOW BECAUSE I'VE GOT TWO OTHER
COMMITTEES GOING RIGHT NOW AS
WELL. SO.
MADAM SECRETARY, WOULD YOU OPEN
THE ROLL FOR AB 1855 ARAMBULA,
PLEASE? OKAY, FILE ITEM THREE,
AB 1855 ARAMBULA MOTION IS DỰ
PASS. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES
AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. OCHOA BOGH NÓ. OCHOA
BOGH NO CORTEZ. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
WILK. NO. WILK. NO. THANK YOU.
MEMBER VALENCIA HAS ARRIVED, WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE PODIUM, AND
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING AB 2447.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND BUENOS DIAS. TO THE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE TEAM
FOR DILIGENTLY WORKING ON THIS
BILL, IN COLLABORATION WITH OUR
TEAM, I'LL BE ACCEPTING ALSO THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS VOICED BY
THE CSU'S. AB 2447 WILL REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM TO DISCLOSE SPECIFIC DATA
FOR THEIR CONTRACTS,
SUBCONTRACTS, PURCHASE ORDERS,
AND INVESTMENTS. DATA COLLECTED
WILL IDENTIFY RECIPIENTS, ITEMS
PURCHASED, TRANSACTION TYPES,
AND A DESCRIPTION OF THE NEED
FOR THE EXPENDITURE. THE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
INDIVIDUAL NAMES OF RECIPIENTS
WILL NOT BE PUBLISHED. WHILE THE
CSU CURRENTLY PUBLISHES A
GENERAL EXPENDITURE PLAN ON
THEIR WEBSITE, THE DATA DOES NOT
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT DETAILS ON
THOSE EXPENDITURES AND ONLY
PROVIDES THE TOTAL AMOUNT
EXPENDED FOR EACH CATEGORY.
COLLECTING THIS DATA WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
PROVIDE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THEIR SPENDING COMPARES
TO THE RESERVES. SURPLUSES AND
OPERATING BUDGET. WITH ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS MY GOOD
FRIEND, MR. BRIAN HAR, THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BRIAN HOWE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. WE WANT TO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR CARRYING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR US, THE BILL
IS VERY SIMPLE. WE ARE, ASKING
THE CSU TO, PRODUCE ON AN
EXTERNAL WEBSITE TO POST THEIR
SPENDING SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE INFORMATION THAT ARE TIMELY
AND ACCURATE AS WE HEAD INTO A
VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR
AHEAD, THERE ARE TWO CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE USED, SERVICES LIKE
OPENGOV OPEN GOV. .ORG THAT HAS
REALLY SHOWN AND FIELDED SOME
VERY POSITIVE, RESEARCH AND
FINDINGS FOR US, CAMPUSES SUCH
AS CSU DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND CSU
SAN LUIS OBISPO, WE JUST WANT TO
FACILITATE THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY
TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES ABOUT WHAT
CSU DOES WITH THEIR RESOURCES.
WE'RE TRYING TO, ADDRESS THEIR
REPORTING INFORMATION. OUR
ACCURATE AND TIMELY. SO, WE URGE
YOUR. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY.
WELL. THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
2447 HERE IN ROOM 2100? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF 2447.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M ADRIANA GÓMEZ, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE CSU OFFICE OF
THE CHANCELLOR, HERE TO SPEAK IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2447, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
CSU TO PUBLISH ALL EXPENDITURES
AND TRANSFERS OF STATE FUNDS,
INCLUDING INVESTMENTS ABOVE
10,000, ON A PUBLIC WEBSITE. I
WANT TO START OFF BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE AUTHOR, HIS
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT WITH CSU AND
THEIR WORK TO MINIMIZE SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS. THE CSU SHARES THE
AUTHOR'S GOAL OF TRANSPARENCY,
AND THAT IS EVIDENT BY OUR
EXISTING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WEBSITE, WHERE
THE PUBLIC CAN TRACK ALL
EXPENDITURES. OVER 50,000 ANNUAL
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS, EXTERNAL
FINANCIAL AUDIT REPORTS, AND
UTILIZE AN INTERACTIVE PORTAL
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO CUSTOMIZE
FINANCE SEARCHES BY UNIVERSITY
AND FUND. AND THIS WAS THE OPEN
GOV FEATURE REFERENCED BY THE
SPONSORS. WITH THAT BEING SAID,
THE CSU REMAINS OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS IT MAINTAINS A NUMBER
OF PROVISIONS THAT PRESENT
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
WOULD PROVIDE LITTLE TO NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC BENEFIT. THESE
INCLUDE THE EXPENSE THRESHOLD OF
$10,000, WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
OVER 30,000 DATA POINTS, AND THE
PROVISION ALLOWING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO REQUEST ANY
INFORMATION THEY CHOOSE TO BE
INCLUDED AND PUBLISHED WITH THE
EXPENDITURES. THIS PROVISION IS
VAGUE AND SUBJECT TO CHANGE,
WHICH PREVENTS THE CSU FROM
KNOWING WHAT INFORMATION NEEDS
TO BE CAPTURED TO SATISFY THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. THE
MEASURE ALSO TREATS INVESTMENTS
AS EXPENDITURES, WHICH IS NOT
APPROPRIATE OR FEASIBLE. CSU IS
REQUIRED BY LAW TO INVEST IN
MUTUAL FUNDS FROM WHICH
TRANSACTIONS ARE MADE CONSTANTLY
BY A FUND MANAGER. WE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THE SAME
REQUIRED CONTENT PER THIS BILL
FOR EXPENDITURES MONTHLY. AS FOR
INVESTMENTS VIA MUTUAL FUNDS,
TRANSPARENCY IS TOP OF MIND FOR
CSU, AND THAT IS WHY THE
INVESTMENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WAS ESTABLISHED. THIS COMMITTEE
MEETS QUARTERLY TO REVIEW
INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES IN A
PUBLIC HEARING. THE CSU ALSO
MEETS STATE LAW REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORTS. AND
FINALLY, INVESTMENTS ARE ALSO
AUDITED BY AN EXTERNAL THIRD
PARTY THAT REVIEWS OUR FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS. THOSE ARE SHARED
PUBLICLY ON THE SAME SITE
MENTIONED EARLIER, AND THEY
INCLUDE INFORMATION ON TOTAL
INVESTMENTS WITH A BREAKDOWN BY
INVESTMENT TYPE AND FAIR VALUE.
THE CSU SHARES THE AUTHOR'S
MOTIVATIONS FOR TRANSPARENCY.
WE'RE JUST AT DISAGREE ON WHAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES BEYOND WHAT
WE'RE ALREADY DOING, AND WITH
OUR ACCOUNTABILITY SITE AND OUR
INVESTMENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2447? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DÍAS MEMBER. WILK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I WE GOT
THREE. I GOT THREE COMMITTEES
GOING ON RIGHT NOW, SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT I, THAT I MISSED
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION. I SAT ON
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES FOR SIX AND A HALF
YEARS. AND WHEN I WAS READING
THIS, THE 10,000 SEEMED WAY, WAY
TOO LOW, JUST FROM MY EXPERIENCE
. SO I MISS. SO WHAT? SO WHAT'S
THE BACK STORY? WHERE DO YOU
THINK THE ISSUES ARE FAILING?
THIS ISN'T A MEASURE TO PLACE
BLAME ON FAILURE OF AN
INSTITUTION. THIS IS MORE A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE. I COME
FROM A CITY WHERE WE'VE HAD
UNFORTUNATE RECENT CHALLENGES
WHEN IT COMES TO, DISCLOSURE OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS. SO I THINK
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION,
CONSIDERING THE FISCAL DYNAMIC
THAT WE'RE IN NOW AS A STATE, IS
NECESSARY. THE PUBLIC THEN CAN
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE BEING USED
APPROPRIATELY. BUT I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING WRONG WITH DISCLOSING
WHATEVER PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT ON. NO, I DON'T
EITHER. AND THEN WHAT ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF THEIR
THEIR INVESTMENT PACKAGE? IF
IT'S YOU REQUIRE IT IN THIS BILL
MONTHLY THEY MEET QUARTERLY. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WHERE THAT
COULD BE ADJUSTED. SO WHEN IT
COMES TO INVESTMENTS THAT'S DONE
QUARTERLY I MEAN ARE YOU STILL
TALKING TO THE OPPOSITION. OH,
ABSOLUTELY, IN COMMUNICATION
WITH THE OPPOSITION, THEY ALSO
MENTIONED, A COMPONENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE'VE REACHED
OUT TO THE ADMINISTRATION LAST
WEEK. WE'RE WAITING TO HEAR BACK
FROM THEM AS WELL. SO THIS IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT IN MY MIND.
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO BE SO
MOVING FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU,
I ALSO HAD A QUESTION WITH HOW
DID YOU DECIDE UPON THE $10,000
THRESHOLD? BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES
TO PUBLIC FUNDS, THAT'S VERY,
VERY MINIMAL AMOUNT OF FUNDS.
WHAT ISSUE ARE YOU TRYING TO,
BESIDES THE TRANSPARENCY, WHAT
ISSUES PROMPTED YOU TO COME
FORWARD AND REQUEST A $10,000,
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION,
SENATOR, EARLIER THIS YEAR, WE
WENT ON A STRIKE AND BY AND
LARGE, BECAUSE THERE WAS STRONG
DISPUTE AMONGST NUMBERS, THEY
CLAIM THAT THEY HAD, SO MUCH IN
THEIR, IN THEIR RESERVES BASED
ON OUR COUNT, BASED ON OUR
ACCOUNT, WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR
RESERVES ARE SO MUCH HIGHER THAN
WHAT THEY WERE DISCLOSING. SO
WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO, EVERY STEP
THAT WE CAN PURSUE TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ALREADY HAVE THAT. THEY
CLAIM THAT THERE'S ALREADY AN
INTERNAL SITE THAT THEY POST
$50,000, ANY EXPENDITURES, OVER
$50,000 OR MORE. THEY HAVE TO
POST IT, BUT IT'S NOT REALLY
GIVING US ANY ACCURATE
INFORMATION. SO THAT'S WHY WE
CAME UP WITH THE NUMBER 10,000.
WE WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN, START
COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES
VERSUS APPLES TO ORANGES. OKAY.
SO THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE FOR
YOU IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ANNUAL FINANCIAL AUDIT REPORTS
THAT THEY THEY PROVIDE, DO THOSE
REPORTS ACTUALLY HAVE, THE MORE
MINUTE EXPENDITURES BY THE
UNIVERSITIES? I HAVE NOT, I HAVE
NOT SEEN THE REPORT IN DETAILS,
BUT, BY AND LARGE, I THINK THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING RIGHT
NOW IS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
PURSUE TRANSPARENCY. WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND A LOT OF THE
MECHANISMS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
USE. THEY SAY THEY HAVE AN
EXTERNAL AUDITORS, THAT HELPS
THEM WITH THIS REPORTING. AGAIN,
A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THEIR
REPORTING ARE FLAWED IN OUR
OPINION. SO WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH, SOME, SOME STEPS AND
MEASURES WHERE WE CAN GET SOME
REAL DETAILED, ACCURATE
INFORMATION. SO TWO COMMENTS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLAWED,
COULD YOU EXPAND A LITTLE BIT AS
TO WHAT YOU MEAN BY FLAWED? AND
NUMBER TWO, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AUDITS, I BELIEVE THE AUDIT
REPORTS ARE DONE BY A THIRD
EXTERNAL, ENTITY, AND THOSE
CANNOT BE FLAWED. THOSE HAVE TO
BE PRETTY ACCURATE. SO IN THE
PAST, WHEN YOU FOLKS ARE
ANALYZING THE FINANCIAL REPORTS
OF THE UNIVERSITIES, HAVE YOUR
HAS YOUR GROUP ACTUALLY UTILIZE
THESE AUDIT REPORTS THAT ARE
MORE, MUCH MORE SPECIFIC IN
DETAIL BECAUSE THOSE ARE ALSO
PUBLICLY, DISCLOSED. YEAH, OUR
MEMBERS HAVE UTILIZED THEM AND
DID AND DID COMPARE THOSE
NUMBERS TO THE NUMBERS THAT WE
COME UP WITH. AND THAT IS WHY WE
FEEL STRONGLY THAT THAT NUMBER,
$50,000, JUST DOES NOT WORK FOR
US. SO WE WANTED TO SEE IF WE
CAN LOWER THAT THRESHOLD, SO
THAT WE CAN GET SOME MORE UP TO
DATE INFORMATION. SO WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM YOU IS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE AUDIT REPORTS AND
SEEING A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE
AUDIT REPORTS, FIGURES AND THE
ACTUAL DOCUMENTS ARE BEING,
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS, NO, WE WOULD WE
WOULD CONSIDER ANY NUMBERS THAT
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DISCLOSE.
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
NUMBERS THAT THEY DISCLOSE ON
THOSE, WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
SHARE WITH THEIR AUDITORS, THEY
PICK AND CHOOSE WHAT THEY WANT
TO SHARE. WE ARE WE ARE TRYING
TO NARROW DOWN, AS MANY
INFORMATION AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
GET RIGHT NOW SO THAT MOVING
FORWARD IN A VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEARS AHEAD, SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE THE
INFORMATION NEEDED FOR US TO
ENTER INTO BARGAINING AGREEMENT
WITH THEM. SO WITH THE AUDIT
REPORTS, ARE YOU STATING THAT ON
ON THE RECORD THAT THEY THEY
ONLY SELECTIVELY CHOOSE WHAT TO
REPORT ON THESE AUDIT REPORTS.
SO THIS THIS IS COMING FROM A
MEMBERSHIP I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCREPANCIES IN TERMS OF
NUMBERS, WE WANT TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT. ADDRESS THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE, I'M USING THE
WORD FLAWS BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
WORDS THAT ARE COMING FROM MY
MEMBERSHIP WHEN IT COMES TO
NUMBERING, SO WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT AT THE SAME TIME.
SO LET ME GO BACK. ARE YOU
STATING THAT THE AUDIT REPORTS
ARE FLAWED, I CAN'T, NO, I'M NOT
SAYING THAT THEY'RE FLAWED, BUT
THIS THESE ARE COMMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM COMING FROM THE
FIELD. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS THE RIGHT STEP FOR US TO
ADDRESS, SOME INCONSISTENCIES
COMING FROM THAT, COMING FROM
THE CSU. OKAY. I'M GOING TO GIVE
THE CSU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YEAH. SO, THE AGENT,
THE THIRD PARTY ENTITY THAT WE
HIRE FOR OUR AUDITS, OUR THIRD
PARTY AUDITS IS KPMG, WHICH I'M
FORTUNATELY BLANKING ON THE
ACRONYM. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT,
BUT I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU.
THEY'RE A REPUTABLE FINANCIAL
AUDITOR, AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WE DO NOT PICK AND CHOOSE WHAT
WE DECIDE. IT'S A THIRD PARTY
AUDITOR THAT'S CONDUCTING THIS
AUDIT, AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
TAKE CSU'S WORD FOR IT, ALSO,
THIS IS A VERY REPUTABLE
AUDITING SOURCE. SO, IN ĐOAN, IT
APPEARS THERE HAS BEEN
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN WHO THE
SPONSORS HAVE HIRED TO AUDIT
VERSUS US. BUT I CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHO THEY'VE HIRED TO CONDUCT
THEIR OWN AUDITS, WE DID, WE DID
SUGGEST AN AMENDMENT TO MOVE THE
BILL TO 50,000 EXPENSE REPORTING
TO MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF DATA,
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
OVERWHELM PEOPLE, AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
SUGGESTED, AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THE AUDITS WITH, WITH
EVERYONE ON THE COMMITTEE, AND
WE'VE ALSO SHARED THEM WITH,
WITH THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. SO I
HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
YOUR AUDIT REPORT. DO YOU HAVE,
DO THEY EXPECT THEY EXPECT AND,
AND DISCLOSE EXPENDITURES THAT
ARE AT THE LEVEL OF 10,000. SO
THE SINCE IT IS A THE REPORT
THAT IS PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE, IT DOESN'T GET INTO
LIKE LINE ITEMS OF ALL OF OUR
EXPENSES BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY LONG, BUT WE HAVE ON
OUR FINANCIAL FINANCIAL
TRANSPARENCY WEBSITE, THERE IS
VERY VISIBLY RIGHT WHEN YOU GET
ON THAT WEBSITE, A LINK THAT
LEADS YOU TO ALL OF OUR
EXPENSES, OVER $50,000, AND YOU
CAN DO IT BY NOTHING AND 50,000,
BUT NOT THERE'S NOTHING PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE THAT SHOWS A 10,000
THRESHOLD, NOT AT 10,000, BUT WE
DO HAVE OUR THE OPEN GOV PORTAL
THAT WAS REFERENCED, DOES HAVE,
EXPENDITURES AND REVENUES AND
THEN IT'LL SAY SOURCES OF EACH
EXPENDITURE OR THE SOURCES OF
THE REVENUE DỰ AND THEN WHERE
THE EXPENDITURE GOES. AND THEN
FROM THERE YOU CAN CLICK AND GET
AS GRANULAR AS YOU WOULD LIKE,
AS MORE LINE DETAIL IS THAT.
YEAH. BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE IT. I
WILL IT DOESN'T SAY $10,000 WENT
TO THIS. IT SAYS THE OVERALL
NUMBER THAT WENT TO LIKE
FINANCIAL AID OR SOMETHING I MAY
ADD. YEAH. WELL GO GO AHEAD.
SENATOR, IF I MAY ADD, SO OUR
TEAM TOOK A LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE AUDITS AND THEY ARE VERY
HIGH LEVEL, AT LEAST IN OUR
OPINION. THEY'RE NOT
COMPREHENSIVE. THEY'RE NOT
EVALUATING EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR
SPENT IN THE CSU SYSTEM, AND
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE THINK A MORE
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AT THIS THRESHOLD IS
NECESSARY. AGAIN THE AUDITING IS
WELCOMED AND APPRECIATED. BUT
AGAIN, IT'S NOT THE DETAIL THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR WHEN IT COMES
TO THE INFORMATION. ĐOAN OKAY.
SENATOR WILK. SO QUESTION. SO I
SENT ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD
AND WE CHANGED AUDITING FIRMS
EVERY THREE YEARS BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO COZY OF A
RELATIONSHIP. DOES THE CSU
OPERATE UNDER THE SAME
PRINCIPLE? THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
I'M I'M NOT SURE HOW LONG WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH KPMG. I'D HAVE
TO CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU, BUT I'M
HAPPY TO DO SO. OKAY, ONE MORE.
SO, LAST AUDIT, DID WERE THERE
ANY FINDINGS THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THE SYSTEM?
TYPICALLY AT THE BEGINNING THEY
THEY DO INCLUDE SUGGESTIONS THAT
ARE EASY FOR EVERYONE TO LOOK
THROUGH. OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD,
I DON'T RECALL THE SPECIFIC
SUGGESTIONS AT THIS MOMENT, BUT
I WILL SAY ON OUR FINANCIAL
TRANSPARENCY WEBSITE THAT HAS
ALL OF THIS EXPENDITURE
INFORMATION, THERE IS AN ICON
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
MAKE SUGGESTIONS AS WELL. WELL,
I WASN'T TALKING ABOUT
SUGGESTIONS. I'M TALKING ABOUT
FINDINGS. SO WHEN THEY DO THE
AUDIT, IF THEY FIND THINGS THAT
ARE WRONG OR NEED TO BE TWEAKED
OR CORRECTED, THERE'S I DON'T
RECALL ANY MAJOR THERE MAY NOT,
THERE MAY NOT AT THE MOMENT.
THERE MAY NOT BE. YEAH. YEAH.
THERE. YOU LOVE IT WHEN THERE'S
NONE. YEAH. THEY'RE NOT STICKING
OUT TO ME AT THE MOMENT. YEAH.
VERY GOOD. YES. AND TO, TO
REITERATE THE POINT THAT I MADE
EARLIER THIS IS NOT TO POINT THE
FINGER AT THE CSU'S. WE'RE NOT
GOING ON A ON A MISSION TO FIND
FAULT AT THE CSU SYSTEM. AGAIN,
THIS IS MORE OF A TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE, AND I APPRECIATE THE
DATA POINT THAT WAS BROUGHT UP,
THE 30,000 NUMBER OF LISTINGS
THAT THIS COULD POTENTIALLY
BRING, AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE WILLING AND
OPEN TO DO THE 50,000. SO IN MY
ANALYSIS, IF YOU'RE WILLING AND
OPEN TO MEET US AT 50,000, I
THINK IT'S FAIR FOR US TO ASK
THE PUBLIC TO ASK FOR THE
$10,000 THRESHOLD, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S ONLY $30,000, 30,000
BULLET POINTS FOR THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM. DID YOU SAY ONLY 30,000?
ONLY 30,000? ONLY 30,000. SO
WITHIN YOUR BILL, IS THERE AN
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES WHO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO MEET THIS
NEED? THERE IS NOT. THERE IS
NOT. BUT WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACTUALLY YIELD SAVINGS LONG
TERM BASED ON THESE FINDINGS, I
THINK IT'S A MERITED APPROACH.
OKAY. SO, ALL RIGHT. WONDERFUL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. Ở. WE NEED A MOTION. YEAH.
SO HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
I AM GOING TO MOVE THE BILL AND
I AM GOING TO VOTE FOR IT TODAY.
I'M GOING TO I NEED TO DELVE IN
A LITTLE A LITTLE. I KNOW YOU'RE
A GOOD AUTHOR, SO I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT TODAY, BUT RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE IT. IF I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE MOVING FORWARD. SO I
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THERE'S AMENDMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE, DID HE SAY? OH, YES,
HE DID. OKAY ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PROPOSED.
I, OPENED WITH THAT COMMENT.
OKAY. SOME CONCERNS THAT THERE
PERFECT. THANK YOU. MERRILEES.
I'M GOING TO ABSTAIN AT THIS
MOMENT AND WANT TO SEE THE BILL
COME BACK TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S BEEN ANY ACCOMMODATIONS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE, BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE IN FULL TRANSPARENCY.
I'M ALL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY, BUT
I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE,
WE ARE AT A POINT WHERE IT'S
REASONABLE AS FAR AS BEING ABLE
TO DO THE WORK, AND THAT MEANS
HAVING THE CAPACITY TO HAVE THE,
THE ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL, BOTH WITH THE WORKFORCE
REQUIRED AS WELL AS THE FUNDING,
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE CAN
REQUIRE. BUT IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE WORKFORCE OR THE FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT, THEN WE'RE AT
A LOSS, WE ACHIEVE NOTHING, SO
WITH THAT, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
17 AB 2447 VALENCIA. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN OCHOA. BOG. CORTEZ.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ LIMON. WILK.
ĐÃ. WILK I THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
MEMBER WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. MEMBER
MCKINNON. WELCOME. 26 ALL RIGHT.
MEMBER MACMURRAY, YOU WILL BE,
PRESENTING AB 2998. YES.
WELCOME. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, OF THE
COMMITTEE, I AM HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2998, A CRUCIAL MEASURE
DESIGNED TO AUTHORIZE MINORS TO
POSSESS AND ADMINISTER NALOXONE
HYDROCHLORIDE, SUCH AS NARCAN,
IN SCHOOLS AND OTHER PUBLIC
SETTINGS, AS A MEANS TO SWIFTLY
RESPOND TO OPIOID OVERDOSES. AB
2998 ALSO ENSURES THAT MINORS
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH TO ASSIST
SOMEONE EXPERIENCING AN OPIOID
OVERDOSE ARE PROTECTED FROM
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES. ACES. THIS
PROVISION NOT ONLY ENCOURAGES
PROACTIVE INTERVENTION, BUT ALSO
PROMOTES A CULTURE OF COMPASSION
AND SUPPORT FOR THOSE IN NEED.
AB 2998 REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP FORWARD IN ADDRESSING
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AMONG MINORS BY
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
HARM REDUCTION STRATEGIES AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING
MEDICATION, WE ARE TAKING
PROACTIVE MEASURES TO SAFEGUARD
THE WELL-BEING OF OUR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITIES. LET US MOVE FORWARD
WITH RESOLVE AND DETERMINATION
TO PASS THIS CRUCIAL MEASURE FOR
THE BETTERMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
JOINING ME TODAY IS MARTHA
ALVAREZ, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT,
AND AMANDA DICKEY, REPRESENTING
THE SANTA CLARA OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
AND WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. VICE CHAIR. WOMAN OTOBO
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
MY NAME IS MARTHA ALVAREZ, AND
I'M THE CHIEF OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE L.A. UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I AM HERE TODAY
AS A PROUD SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY
BILL 2998 BY ESTÁN WIENER AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
IN RESPONSE TO THE DEVASTATING
EPIDEMIC OF OPIOID OVERDOSES IN
LOS ANGELES, LÀ L.A. UNIFIED
IMPLEMENTED NUMEROUS INITIATIVES
, INCLUDING OUR OPIOID TASK
FORCE LAUNCHED THIS SCHOOL YEAR
IN FALL OF 2023, WHICH EXPANDS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES TO ALIGN
EFFORTS AND KEEP OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY SAFE. IN
ADDITION TO FULLY ENGAGING
FAMILIES IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND IDENTIFYING
SIGNS FOR PARENTS, CARETAKERS,
AND YOUTH, WE HAVE ALSO LAUNCHED
COURSES ON THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED FAMILY ACADEMY TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON LOCATIONS
FOR DIRECT SUPPORT, AS WELL AS
INFORMATION ON INCREASING
AWARENESS ON FENTANYL AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PREVENTION
EFFORTS. IN OCTOBER OF 2022, LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED BEGAN RECEIVING
OVER-THE-COUNTER NARCAN, ONE
BRAND OF NALOXONE THROUGH
CALIFORNIA'S NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT. THESE
DOSES ARE AVAILABLE AT ALL K-12
CAMPUSES, ADULT EDUCATION
CENTERS, AND EARLY EDUCATION
CENTERS. THEY ARE ALSO PROVIDED
TO SCHOOL NURSES AND OTHER
TRAINED PERSONNEL, AND HAVE
PROVEN TO BE CRITICAL IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST OVERDOSE. HOWEVER,
STAFF THAT CAN ACCESS THE
MEDICATION ARE NOT ALWAYS
AVAILABLE IN THE IMMEDIATE
MOMENTS OF AN OVERDOSE, AND
FIRST RESPONDERS MAY NOT MAY BE
MINUTES AWAY. IN FEBRUARY 2023,
L.A. UNIFIED CREATED A POLICY
SUPPORTED BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
NOT ISSUE FORMAL DISCIPLINE IF A
STUDENT CARRIES NALOXONE ON
CAMPUS AS AN EXTRA LAYER OF
PROTECTION AGAINST THE FENTANYL
CRISIS, AB 2998 IS NECESSARY TO
CLARIFY THIS AUTHORIZATION IN
STATUTE AND CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
STATEWIDE TOOL IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST FENTANYL. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE CHANCES OF
IMMEDIATE LIFE SAVING
COUNTER-COUNTERMEASURES IN CASE
OF A FENTANYL OVERDOSE. FOR THIS
REASON, LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 2998. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT STUDENT HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING, AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISS ALVAREZ. THANK
YOU, VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS AMANDA
DICKEY. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE FENTANYL IS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR 1 IN 5 DEATHS
AMONG CALIFORNIA YOUTH AGED 15
TO 24. IN SANTA CLARA ALONE,
FENTANYL RELATED DEATHS
INCREASED BY 1,000% BETWEEN 2018
AND 2021, FROM 11 DEATHS TO 154.
LIKE LAUSD, OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS PARTNERED WITH THE
COUNTY TO ESTABLISH THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OPIOID OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROJECT, WHICH IS A
MULTI-PRONGED APPROACH THAT
EDUCATES STUDENTS ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF FENTANYL. WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING NALOXONE AT SCHOOLS.
THIS PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED JUST
TWO YEARS AGO AND HAS ALREADY
BEEN USED TO SAVE SEVERAL LIVES.
WHILE THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL, IT STILL ISN'T
ENOUGH BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
LOSING KIDS, WHICH IS WHY WE
NEED AB 22998. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW STUDENTS TO CARRY NALOXONE
ON CAMPUS, WHICH HAS BEEN FDA
APPROVED SINCE 1970 AND HAS NO
KNOWN RISKS. SO THAT IF THEY OR
ANOTHER STUDENT EXPERIENCES AN
OVERDOSE, THEY CAN SAVE A LIFE.
SO EVERYONE WHO HAS CHILDREN OR
WHO HAS BEEN A CHILD KNOWS THAT
KIDS CAN MAKE BAD CHOICES, AND
THAT IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR ONE
BAD CHOICE, LIKE EXPERIMENTING
WITH DRUGS TO BE FOLLOWED BY
ANOTHER BAD CHOICE. LIKE BEING
SO AFRAID OF THE CONSEQUENCES
THAT THEY ASK THEIR FRIENDS NOT
TO TELL ANYONE THAT THEY'RE
FEELING SICK, IT'S NOT RATIONAL,
BUT IT IS THE REALITY. AND IT IS
HOW KIDS THINK SOMETIMES. AND WE
KNOW THAT YOUTH HAVE DIED
BECAUSE THEY WERE TOO AFRAID TO
ASK FOR HELP. SO WHILE WE AT
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE
OBVIOUSLY DO NOT CONDONE
STUDENTS BAD CHOICES, WE WILL
ALWAYS, ALWAYS SUPPORT POLICIES
THAT KEEP CHILDREN ALIVE. AB
2998 IS ONE SUCH POLICY. BY
ALLOWING STUDENTS THEMSELVES TO
CARRY NALOXONE, IT INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT A LIFE WILL BE
SAVED. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NOW WE'LL PROCEED WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 2998
HERE IN ROOM 2100. THANK YOU.
TOM RENFREE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, SARAH KAMINSKY, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LETICIA
GARCIA WITH THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS OF SCHOOL AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
NOW, WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2998, SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL
. THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC, AND IT
DOESN'T ONLY HIT YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE RECENTLY HAD A RETIRED
LEGISLATOR WHO WAS 60 YEARS OLD
WHO PASSED, WHICH WAS SHOCKING
TO ME. AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
BE PROACTIVE, TO SAVE KIDS IS A
GOOD THING. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL AND I MOVE IT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WILK. I ALSO HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS, SPACE OF
FENTANYL ALSO ON THE MEDICAL
SIDE, TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE THAT CAN
HELP US ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
LOSE ANOTHER LIFE TO FENTANYL,
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY, AND, MADAM
SECRETARY, WOULD YOU CALL. OH
SORRY, MEMBER MCKENNA, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
MA'AM, THANK YOU, MADAM
SECRETARY. FINAL ITEM 26 AB 2998
MCKENNA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO SEND A JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN OKOBOJI. I OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. GLASER GONZALEZ. LIMÓN.
WILK. ĐÃ. WILK I THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE MEMBER SHIAVO HERE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED NEXT?
PERFECT. YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
AB 3074 WHEN YOU'RE READY, THE
WITNESSES COME TO THE Ở. THEY
SIT. OKAY. SORRY. I WAS JUST IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. AND THEY DO
IT DIFFERENTLY, WE LIKE TO BE,
MORE, WELCOMING. VERY WELCOMING.
YES APPRECIATE THAT, GOOD. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
3074 TO YOU TODAY AS A STUDENT
ATHLETE, I KNOW HOW MUCH PRIDE
AND TEAM SPIRIT COMES FROM
MASCOTS. YET FOR FAR TOO LONG,
SOME MASCOTS HAVE INSTEAD BEEN A
SOURCE OF SHAME AND CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION. AB 3074 WOULD
PROHIBIT ALL PUBLIC K THROUGH 12
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM USING CULTURALLY
INSENSITIVE NATIVE AMERICAN
TERMS FOR SCHOOL OR ATHLETIC
NAMES. MASCOTS AND NICKNAMES.
MASCOTS ARE HUGE PART OF SCHOOL
EVENTS, AND THEY ARE WHAT DRAW
PEOPLE TO DRESS UP FOR THEIR
TEAM OR BUY MEMORABILIA.
HOWEVER, THEY CAN HAVE A REALLY
BIG NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
COMMUNITIES WHOSE LIKENESS IS
USED FOR MASCOTS. SEVERAL
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THESE
NATIVE AMERICAN MASCOTS HAVE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES, FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL AND COMMUNITY LEVEL.
IN 1968, THE NATIONAL CONGRESS
OF AMERICAN INDIANS BEGAN
CAMPAIGNS TO ADDRESS STEREOTYPES
OF NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
POP CULTURE, MEDIA, AND SPORTS.
MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
PURSUIT OF ENDING IN THE AREA OF
UNSANCTIONED NATIVE THEMED
MASCOTS, BUT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPAIGN THROUGH
THIS BILL. FOLLOWING IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF SOME SCHOOLS AND
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAMS THAT
HAVE ALREADY TAKEN THE
INITIATIVE TO CHANGE THEIR NAME.
HART HIGH SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT
JUST WENT THROUGH A NAME CHANGE
PROCESS. THEY HAVE CHANGED THEIR
NAME FROM INDIANS TO THE HAWKS,
AND THE NEW MASCOT BEING VOTED
ON BY THE STUDENT BODY. HOWEVER,
THERE IS STILL OVER 2000 SCHOOLS
NATIONWIDE THAT HAVE NATIVE
AMERICAN THEMED MASCOTS. AB 3074
WILL HELP CREATE A SAFE SPACE IN
SCHOOLS TO MAKE CERTAIN GROUPS,
TO MAKE CERTAIN GROUPS, SCHOOLS
EXPERIENCE BETTER FOR THEY WILL
NO LONGER HAVE TO DEAL WITH
BULLYING, MOCKERY, OR ISOLATION
DUE TO A MASCOT. JOINING ME
TODAY IS CURRENT TREASURER
DANIELLA CIRELLI OF THE HARBOR
MOTEL POMO OF UPPER LAKE, AND
ALSO JULIA ESTRADA, WHO IS AN
ASSEMBLY FELLOW WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID ALVAREZ'S OFFICE TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL. BECAUSE OF
HER INVOLVEMENT IN SCHOOL MASCOT
CHANGE. IN MY COMMUNITY. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS DANIELLE
CRLA. I AM CURRENTLY THE
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL TREASURER FOR
THE POMO OF UPPER LAKE AND AS OF
THREE DAYS AGO WAS ELECTED BY MY
GENERAL MEMBERSHIP AS
CHAIRPERSON AND WILL BE SWORN IN
NEXT MONTH. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHABO AND RAMOS.
AB 3074 THE CALIFORNIA RACIAL
MASCOT ACT. THIS LEGISLATION
PROHIBITS PUBLIC SCHOOLS FROM
USING DEROGATORY NATIVE AMERICAN
TERMS FOR SCHOOLS OR ATHLETIC
TEAM NAMES, MASCOTS, OR
NICKNAMES. SOME EXAMPLES OF
THESE DEROGATORY TERMS INCLUDE
APACHES, BIG REDS, BRAVES,
CHIEFS, CHIEFTAINS, INDIANS,
SAVAGES, SQUAW, AND TRIBE. AND
JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT IN
OUR CULTURE, MANY INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE WILL NOT USE THE TERM
SQUAW. WE REFER TO IT AS THE S
WORD. THAT'S HOW OFFENSIVE MANY
OF MY PEOPLE FIND THAT WORD. AND
UNDER EXISTING LAW, CURRENTLY
ONLY THE TERM REDSKINS IS
PROHIBITED. AS I MENTIONED, THE
POMO TRIBE IN UPPER LAKE, WHERE
THE POMO PEOPLE HAVE RESIDED
SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL. THE
TRIBES IN THAT AREA, INCLUDING
OURS, WHERE WE HAVE SEVEN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES,
HAVE SUFFERED CENTURIES OF
FEDERAL POLICIES WITH SUBJECTED
US TO UNSPEAKABLE CRUELTIES AND
TRAGEDIES THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY
, INCLUDING AN ATTEMPTED
GENOCIDE IN 1850 KNOWN AS THE
BLOODY ISLAND MASSACRE, WHICH
WAS LED BY CAPTAIN ANDREW
KELSEY. KELSEY IRONICALLY, IS
NOW THE NAME OF A TOWN JUST
SOUTH OF UPPER LAKE WHERE OUR
RESERVATION AND TRIBAL OFFICES
ARE LOCATED. THIS HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING LOCAL DISPUTE BETWEEN
TRIBES AND THE KELSEY VILLE
COMMUNITY, WITH UNSUCCESSFUL
ATTEMPTS TO CHANGE THE NAMES.
FOR YEARS, MANY NON-TRIBAL
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS THAT A NAME OR A MASCOT
CAN HAVE ON A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY AND
CONSISTENTLY THREATENED,
FORGOTTEN, AND MISTREATED, WHICH
ALL OF THIS LEADS TO
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA, ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR YOUTHS. AND WE BELIEVE
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE A SAFE PLACE
FOR ALL YOUTH AND INDIGENOUS
YOUTH. STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO ATTEND A SCHOOL THAT IS
MOCKING THEIR CULTURE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO 109
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES, AND
OUR STATE HAS THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
THIS LEGISLATION IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION, STARTING
TAKING ACTIONS TO RECTIFY THE
HISTORIC MISTREATMENT TOWARDS
TRIBES AND RECOGNIZING BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THAT
TRIBAL CULTURE IS SOMETHING TO
BE CELEBRATED AND APPRECIATED,
RATHER THAN MOCKED AND
APPROPRIATED. IN CONCLUSION, THE
POMO OF UPPER LAKE SUPPORTS AB
3074 AND ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
SPONSORS FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
TO BRIEFLY INTRODUCE MYSELF, MY
NAME IS JULIA ESTRADA AND I AM A
NATIVE AMERICAN, FORMER ALUMNI
OF HART HIGH SCHOOL AND OOPS IN
THE CITY OF SANTA CLARITA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, CHÁVEZ
DISTRICT. AND I WAS THE STUDENT
THAT LED THE INITIATIVE TO
RETIRE THE INDIAN MASCOT BACK IN
2020 AFTER MY GRADUATION, IT WAS
A YEAR LONG EFFORT. AND IF
ANYBODY IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
HART DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD,
THERE WERE A LOT OF SWING VOTES
THAT I HAD TO GET, BUT IT WAS A
PROCESS THAT WAS IN THAT
INCORPORATED TRIBAL VOICES AS
WELL AS STUDENT ADVOCATES AND
ULTIMATELY, WE MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION TO RETIRE THE MASCOT
AND HAVE GONE FORTH WITH
APPROVING THE HAWKS AND
IMPLEMENTING THAT NEW MASCOT. AS
OF MARCH 19TH OF THIS YEAR, AND
I THINK FOR MY TESTIMONY, I WANT
TO SPEAK TO THE STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE AS ONE OF THE ONLY
NATIVE AMERICANS AT HART HIGH
SCHOOL AT THE TIME. I WAS ALSO A
STUDENT ATHLETE. I WAS ON TRACK,
I DID TENNIS, I WAS, CHIEF OF
THE TOMAHAWK AT THE TIME
YEARBOOK, AND WAS REALLY
INVOLVED IN MY SCHOOL, BUT WOULD
CONSTANTLY ATTEND TENNIS MATCHES
WHERE MY PEERS WOULD DO,
WHIPPING NOISES BY PUTTING THEIR
HANDS OVER THEIR MOUTHS OR,
TRIBAL ASB MEMBERS, WHAT WE CALL
TRIBE LEADERS, WOULD EMERGE FROM
A TEEPEE DURING PEP RALLIES AND
THINGS THAT ARE JUST BLATANTLY
DISRESPECTFUL, IF YOU KNOW ANY
NATIVE AMERICANS AND ARE ALSO
JUST MISREPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
CULTURE, AND WHEN WE THINK OF
NATIVE AMERICAN MASCOTS, WE
OFTEN THINK OF A PLAINS INDIAN
WITH A BIG FEATHERY HEADDRESS
AND THAT'S ULTIMATELY NOT WHAT
CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE. AND IT'S
JUST PROOF THAT WE ARE
CHARACTERIZING NATIVE AMERICANS
IN OUR EDUCATIONAL SPACES AS AS
ONE IMAGE, AND ALMOST LIKE
MAKING THEM A MYTHOLOGICAL
CREATURE SIMILAR TO THAT OF
THINGS THAT DON'T EXIST ANYMORE,
LIKE VIKINGS, ETC. AND SO I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WANT TO CREATE
SPACES IN HIGH SCHOOLS, MIDDLE
SCHOOLS, ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE INCLUSIVE OF
ALL PEOPLE. AND ALTHOUGH WE MAY
BE FAR AND FEW, LIKE I WAS AT
HART HIGH SCHOOL, WE MATTER. AND
WHEN WE'RE DRAFTING LEGISLATION
THAT IS ADVOCATING FOR MORE,
BETTER PROTECTIONS FOR NATIVE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE HIGH SUICIDE
AND DEPRESSION RATES, WE ALSO
HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
IMPLICATIONS THAT MASCOTS LIKE
THIS PLACE ON OUR NATIVE
STUDENTS. JUST THIS YEAR, THE
YEARBOOK PRINTED A GOING AWAY
KIND OF MEMORIAL TO THE INDIAN,
AND IT WAS ALMOST KIND OF A SLAP
IN THE FACE AFTER A VERY LONG
PROCESS. AND A NATIVE CURRENT
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENT AT HART
HIGH SCHOOL SENT ME THIS PHOTO
THAT JUST SHOWS FROM 1949 TO
1994, ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS OF THE INDIAN THAT WE
HAD AT OUR HIGH SCHOOL. AND IN A
LOT OF THESE BOARD MEETINGS, I
ATTENDED, IT WAS NO, IT WAS
NEVER THAT BAD. IT WAS NEVER
SORRY, I'M GETTING EMOTIONAL. IT
WAS NEVER THAT INSENSITIVE. BUT
AFTER A YEAR OF WORK, THIS IS
HOW NATIVE VOICES ARE BEING
REPRESENTED IN OUR CURRENT
YEARBOOK. AND IT JUST SHOWS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
EDUCATE AND IN CITIES IN
PARTICULAR, LIKE SANTA CLARITA,
WHERE THERE AREN'T A LOT OF
NATIVE PEOPLE, THIS IS THE PLACE
FOR THAT ADVOCACY. AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD AND
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
WORKING CONSISTENTLY SINCE 1968
TO ASK FOR THESE CHANGES. AND SO
IT'S OUR DUTY TO JUST FOLLOW
THROUGH AND COMMIT TO CHANGING
THIS. THANK YOU. AT THE STATE
LEVEL, BECAUSE IT'S LONG OVERDUE
AND MANY OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
IT ALREADY. AND THERE'S RESEARCH
TO PROVE THAT IT GENUINELY
CHANGES HOW NON-NATIVE PEOPLE
PERCEIVE NATIVE AMERICANS. SO
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. I VOTE ON AB 3074.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY, WHILE WE
CONTINUE WITH OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3074, I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT
YOU HAVE ON HAND. I DON'T THINK
I RECEIVED IT NO, WE DIDN'T
RECEIVE IT. SO IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND, I'M SURE OUR MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOUR REFERRING TO.
NOW WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
3074. HI, TIFFANY MOCK CFT, A
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. WE
JUST WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL AND COMMEND THE
COURAGE OF THOSE SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS, PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, THE SUPERINTENDENT
AND BOARD OF EDUCATION, AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES. ANY CHILD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT RACHEL BHAGWAT WITH
ACLU, CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
STRONG SUPPORT PAMELA LOPEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE TẠI TRIBE IN THE
TULE RIVER TRIBE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TONY THURMOND, STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, ON BEHALF OF 6
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE STATE, I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
AS YOU THINK. I LIKE TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOUR
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS. AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE WITNESSES TESTIMONY,
WE, THERE ARE DEEP INFLICTED,
PAINFUL WOUNDS FROM THIS
PRACTICE OF RACISM AND CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION. AFTER ALL, THIS
NATION AND THIS STATE HAS DONE
TO THE FIRST PEOPLE OF THIS
STATE, THIS IS THE LEAST THAT WE
CAN DO, IS TO CHANGE THIS
PRACTICE ONCE AND FOR ALL. I
HAVE THE HONOR OF CHAIRING THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON
ALLOWING NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS TO WEAR TRIBAL REGALIA,
MAKING SURE THAT WE TEACH THE
RIGHT THINGS ABOUT THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE'S HISTORY. AND I
THINK WHAT WE CAN DO AS A START
IS MAKE SURE THAT WE PASS AB 374
AND END THIS TRADITION FOREVER.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SUPERINTENDENT. OKAY. WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
QUICK COMMENTS. ONE I THOUGHT
THAT WE OUTLAWED SQUAW. OR IS
THAT JUST FOR, LIKE, STATE PARKS
AND STATE PROPERTY IS. IT WAS
JUST THAT BECAUSE WHEN I LEARNED
WHAT THAT MEANT, I WAS LIKE I
WAS LIKE HORRIFIED. SO I CAME IN
HERE BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN LOCAL
CONTROL. LIKE YOU ADVOCATED IN
YOUR SCHOOL, WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT AS WELL. AND YOU DID A
GREAT JOB. I LIKE LOCAL CONTROL.
I THINK WE DO TOO MUCH STUFF IN
SACRAMENTO TELLING PEOPLE WHAT
TO DO. BUT YOUR TESTIMONY WAS SO
COMPELLING THAT I AM GOING TO
VOTE AYE ON THIS AND THROW AWAY
MY PRINCIPLE OF LOCAL CONTROL
BECAUSE YOU MOVE ME SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND I WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT. WITH REGARDS
TO, YOU KNOW, WE TALK ABOUT THE
MASCOTS AND SO FORTH, SOME TAKE
PRIDE IN YOU MAY FIND IT
OFFENSIVE, BUT OVERALL, WHEN IT
COMES TO THE MASCOTS, I KNOW
THAT YOU MAY THINK IT WOULD BE
OFFENSIVE SOMETIMES, BUT I KNOW
THAT LIKE, FOR INSTANCE, IN OUR
CITY WHERE THE THUNDERBIRDS, OUR
MASCOTS, ARE ENDEARED, I HAVE A
DAUGHTER WHO IS IN UTAH, AND
THEY, THEY HAVE A TIGER, KIND OF
LIKE A TIGER. AND THEY, YOU
KNOW, THEY LOVE THE TIGER. SO
JUST FOR THE FOR PLANTING A
LITTLE BIT OF A HEALING, SEED IN
YOUR HEART. NOT EVERYBODY
CONSIDERS ĐÃ A MASCOT AS A
NEGATIVE, AS A NEGATIVE
COMPONENT OR REPRESENTATION OF
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY'RE,
THEY'RE UTILIZING. SO I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES IT'S A
SENSE OF PRIDE, FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO HAVE THE MASCOTS, IN
THEIR, IN THEIR SCHOOLS. SO IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY, I AND I SAW
WHAT YOU SHOWED ON THERE AND
YEAH, SOME OF THOSE WERE
DEFINITELY VERY, VERY OFFENSIVE.
AND I, I'M NOT GOING TO JUSTIFY
PEOPLE'S, THERE WAS BUT YES,
ABSOLUTELY OFFENSIVE. AND I CAN
SEE HOW YOU WOULD BE OFFENSIVE
ON THAT END. AND I YOU KNOW, I
CAN'T APOLOGIZE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS, BUT I CAN UNDERSTAND
YOUR SENSITIVITY TOWARDS THIS
SUBJECT MATTER, I COMMEND YOU
FOR THE ADVOCACY THAT YOU'VE
DONE, LOCALLY ON THAT END AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY, BUT, BUT NO, NO,
THAT FOR SOME IT WAS NOT
NECESSARILY IN A NEGATIVE LIGHT,
BUT FOR SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS, THEY'RE PROUD.
THEY'RE PROUD OF THEIR, THEIR,
THEIR MASCOTS, IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
SO WITH THAT, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OH, I'M
SORRY. MEMBERS, PLEASE. WE
WELCOME YOUR CLOSING. THANK YOU.
I WANT TO I WANT TO THANK MY
WITNESSES WITH THEIR POWERFUL
TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BEING OPEN AND
WILLING TO HEAR AND LISTEN AND
SUPPORT TODAY. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL. I THINK,
YOU KNOW, I THINK TO YOUR POINT
THAT THIS IS WHY THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO START THIS
CONVERSATION, BECAUSE I THINK
CERTAINLY THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
IT'S UNINTENDED, RIGHT, BUT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY
BEING HARMED BY IT. AND THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
TO MOVE FORWARD AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT EDUCATION HAPPENS.
I'VE HAD, YOU KNOW, A GROWN SIX
FOOT THREE NATIVE AMERICAN MAN
IN MY OFFICE CRYING WHEN HE WAS
REMEMBERING ABOUT OFFENSIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN STEREOTYPES IN
HIS SCHOOL EXPERIENCE. RIGHT. SO
THESE ARE, THESE ARE ONGOING
TRAUMAS. AND WE CERTAINLY
THROUGH OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM,
DON'T WANT TO BE A PART OF
PERPETUATING THAT. AND I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP FOR US TO MAKE,
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN RESPECT
IS INTENDED, THAT RESPECT IS
ALSO RECEIVED. RIGHT. AND
RESPECT IS AND THERE'S A JOINT
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT
RESPECT LOOKS LIKE. AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. SO
APPRECIATE SUPPORT. AND I VOTE
FOR 3074 TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHILE ITEM 27 AB 3074
SHIAVO MOTION IS DỰ PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN OCHOA A OKOBOJI. CORTEZ.
GLASER GLASER I GONZALEZ. LIMÓN.
WILK HI. WILK. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL PLACE THAT BILL ON
HOLD FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING YOU TODAY.
AND THANK YOU TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT AS WELL.
SO OUT OF COURTESY, WE'RE GOING
TO ALLOW, MEMBER JONES, PRESENT
HIS BILL. IF YOU DON'T MIND.
UNLESS IF, IF UNLESS YOU HAVE A
TIME SENSITIVITY. IS THAT OKAY?
HE'S BEEN HERE FOR A WHILE,
WAITING GRACIOUSLY. SO OUT OF
COURTESY. NUMBER 26, AB 3142. SO
YOU PRESENTING AB 3142. THANK
YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR. AB 3142,
WHICH EXPANDS THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION CENTER
AT THE WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE
BY ADDING A MOBILE UNIT IN ORDER
TO IMPROVE THE REACH OF THE
CURRENT CENTER IN 2022. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEADERS AGREED TO BUILD A ROAD
MAP TO HELP CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PREPARE TO MEET FUTURE
WORKFORCE NEEDS IN CLIMATE
ACTION. TO FURTHER THIS EFFORT,
THE LEGISLATURE INVESTED $5
MILLION FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT LACCD
TO CREATE THE CALIFORNIA CENTER
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION AT
WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE. AB
3142 HELPS FURTHER THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN AND BUILDS UPON
THE WORK OF THE CENTER FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION BY
CREATING A MOBILE UNIT TO HELP
REACH STUDENTS IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH HANDS ON LEARNING AND
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. AB
3142 ALSO CODIFIES THE CENTER TO
ENSURE ITS MISSION AND PURPOSE
ARE ANCHORED IN STATE LAW. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITH ME TO SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS MARIA VELEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL, SPONSOR TO
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
VICE CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, MARIA LUISA
BELLOWS. I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF CHANCELLOR FRANCISCO
RODRIGUEZ, WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY, AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED, MENTIONED, LACCD IS
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 3142.
AND, AND AS HE MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING STATEMENT, THIS BILL
ADDRESSES A CRITICAL ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION, TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE. THE WEST LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE IS THE ONLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OFFERING CLIMATE. A
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSOCIATE OF ARTS
DEGREE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TWO YEARS AGO, AS
WAS MENTIONED, THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AMPLIFIED THIS
DEGREE AND ALLOCATED THE $5
MILLION TO ESTABLISH THE CENTER
AT WEST L.A. COLLEGE. SINCE
THEN, THE CENTER HAS RECEIVED
NATIONAL RECOGNITION FROM
PRESTIGIOUS, COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES NATIONWIDE. AND AB
3142 WILL CODIFY BY THE CENTER
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION AT
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND RECOGNIZE
THIS CRITICAL AND TIMELY FIELD
OF STUDY. THIS WILL HELP
FACILITATE FUTURE AND PUBLIC,
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDING FOR
THE CENTER. IN ADDITION, AB 3142
WILL ADD THE MOBILE UNIT AS WAS
MENTIONED, TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
THE CENTER'S CLIMATE CHANGE
CURRICULUM THROUGHOUT THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION. THIS
MOBILE UNIT WILL TRAVEL TO LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOLS, ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
AND THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE, TO
PROVIDE HANDS ON EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES, OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL,
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP AND
JUSTICE. AB 3142 WILL FURTHER
INCREASE AWARENESS, MODIFY
BEHAVIORS, AND PREPARE OUR
CURRENT AND NEXT GENERATION OF
WORKERS FOR GREEN AND BLUE
SECTOR JOBS. THESE CAREERS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ALTERING THE
IMPACTS OF GLOBAL WARMING AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU. MA'AM, DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB 3142 HERE IN ROOM 2100?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR GLAZIER. MEMBER.
JONES-SAWYER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. SIR
THANK YOU, MADAM SECRETARY.
WHILE IN 28 AB 3142 JONES-SAWYER
MOTION IS ĐÓ MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER.
I GONZALEZ. LIMON. WILK. HI.
WILK I WILL PLACE THAT ON HOLD
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. SIR GIBSON. YES.
THANK YOU. WELCOME. WELCOME.
MEMBER. GIBSON. SO HAPPY TO SEE
YOU HERE TODAY. VERY GLAD TO SEE
, YOUR BRIGHT SMILE TODAY, AB,
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB 2816.
THAT IS CORRECT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2816, WHICH SEEKS TO ESTABLISH A
SCHOOL MAPPING TECHNOLOGY FOR
THE FIRST RESPONDERS ON K
THROUGH 12 CAMPUSES. SCHOOL
MAPPING TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALLOW
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS TO HAVE
ACCESS MÁS, TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
SCHOOL LAYOUT PRIOR TO ENTERING
THE CAMPUS. THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
NECESSARY FOR BALANCING,
ACCESSIBILITY AND SECURITY TO
ENSURE EFFICIENT COMMUNICATION
FOR AND WITH FIRST RESPONDERS,
ULTIMATELY ENHANCING EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND OUTCOMES. IN 2023
ALONE, THERE WAS THERE WAS A
REPORT OF 346 SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENTS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES, INJURING ABOUT 191
STUDENTS, AND FROM 2018 THROUGH
2023, 1073 PEOPLE WERE WOUNDED
OR KILLED IN SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
96 SCHOOL SHOOTINGS RIGHT HERE
AT HOME, 96 SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENTS HAPPENED WITHIN FIVE
YEARS, RESULTING IN 82 PEOPLE
BEING WOUNDED OR KILLED. THESE
STATISTICS HAVE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED THE
STUDENTS MENTAL WELL-BEING IN
SCHOOLS, CAUSING 58% OF OUR
STUDENTS. OUR BABIES, TO WORRY
ABOUT A SCHOOL SHOOTING
HAPPENING ON THEIR CAMPUS. THUS
CREATING ANXIETY FILLED WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL THAT SHOULD BE A
SAFE PLACE FOR OUR CHILDREN TO
FOCUS ON SCHOOL, WORK, BUT YET
THEIR FOCUS ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE GOING TO COME HOME
ALIVE. OUR CHILDREN DESERVE
BETTER AND THEIR LIVES.
UNFORTUNATELY, EVERY DAY IS ON
THE LINE. EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TIMES ARE VITAL DURING AN EVENT
OF AN EMERGENCY. VICTIMS
SURVIVAL SURVIVAL RATES FALL BY,
FAILED BY 7 TO 10% FOR EVERY
MINUTE WITHOUT AN EMERGENCY
TREATMENT. A TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF
THE EFFECTS OF A DELAY RESPONSE.
AND I WANT TO RECALL TO THIS
BODY OF WHAT HAPPENED IN IVALDI,
TEXAS, WHERE THE RESPONSE TIME
WAS INADEQUATE, AND CHILDREN'S
LIVES WERE LOST AS A RESULT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS DIDN'T KNOW
WHICH WAY TO GO BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A MAPPING PLAN. THEY
COULD NOT FIND THE CHILDREN.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THE LAYOUT OF
THE SCHOOL. THREE OUT OF 19
VICTIMS DIED. MORE THAN AN HOUR
LATER DUE TO THE DUE TO THEIR
INJURIES, WHICH COULD HAVE BEEN,
TREATED. IT IS VITAL THAT WE
SUPPLY A FIRST OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WITH THE MOST
ADVANCED SECURITY SYSTEMS THAT
WILL NOT ONLY DECREASE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TIMES, BUT ALSO GIVE
STUDENTS THE REASSURANCE THEY
NEED, TO EMPHASIZE THEIR SAFETY
AT SCHOOL. ASSEMBLY BILL 2816
HAS ENJOYED A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAVE RECEIVED NO NO VOTES,
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND PASS, OF
COURSE OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. THIS BILL IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2816 IS SUPPORTED BY A
NUMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT PORAC
AND ALSO CPC ĐÃ. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M JUST
COMING BACK. I'M SORRY. SHE GAVE
ME THE GAVEL. I THOUGHT THAT WAS
YOU. GIVE ME THE GAVEL, THANK
YOU, MEMBER GIBSON AND SO WE DO
HAVE LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
SUPPORT? PLEASE PROCEED.
WELCOME. YES SIR, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JOE
HANSEN, AND I WANT TO THANK BOTH
YOURSELVES AND ALL MEMBERS OF
THE STAFF AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR MEETING WITH US
THE TIME AND CONSIDERATION GIVEN
TO US IS MUCH APPRECIATED. I
CURRENTLY LIVE IN MAMMOTH LAKES
WITH MY WIFE AND TWO SMALL
CHILDREN. PRIOR TO THAT, I SPENT
11 YEARS SERVING AS A SPECIAL
OPERATIONS OFFICER IN THE
MARINES AND COMPLETED FOUR
COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS. I NOW
SPECIALIZE IN COMMUNICATING
DURING A CRITICAL INCIDENT WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON K THROUGH 12
SCHOOLS, MORE SPECIFICALLY,
PROVIDING SCHOOL MAPPING DATA
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS. THE
CHALLENGES FACING FIRST
RESPONDERS WHEN THEY ARRIVE AT
THE 911 CALL FOR A SCHOOL ARE
MANY. IT IS TIME SENSITIVE. IT'S
DANGEROUS. FIRST RESPONDERS
OFTEN FIND THEMSELVES WORKING
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS THEY
RARELY HAVE CONTACT WITH. FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE EXPECTED TO
SIMPLY KNOW HOW TO GET TO THE
ART ROOM OR TO THE CAFETERIA IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY WITH
EASE, BUT THAT'S SIMPLY NOT THE
CASE. SCHOOL BLUEPRINTS OR FLOOR
PLANS AS THEY EXIST TODAY ARE
INACCURATE AND NOT DESIGNED FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY ARE
INACCESSIBLE IN THE DISPARATE
SOFTWARE SYSTEMS THAT FIRST
RESPONDERS AND SCHOOLS USE
TODAY. DUE TO THESE PROBLEMS,
THEY ADD CONFUSION TO AN
EMERGENCY SCENARIO INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING ACTIONABLE INFORMATION
JUST IN THE CASE OF A UVALDE,
TEXAS A DIRECT QUOTE FROM THE
AFTER ACTION REPORT READS. THE
SCHEMATIC MAPS OF THE CAMPUS
USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL POINTS OF
ENTRY WERE INACCURATE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TESTIFIED.
EXCUSE ME, TESTIFIED TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE THAT
THEY ASKED WHETHER THEY COULD
GAIN ACCESS TO THE CLASSROOMS
THROUGH WINDOWS, BUT WERE
DETERRED BY THE INACCURATE FLOOR
PLANS. IN THE CASE OF SANDY
HOOK, WHEN OFFICERS CONDUCTED
INITIAL AND SUBSEQUENT SEARCHES
OF THE SCHOOL, NEITHER FLOOR
PLANS NOR SCHEMATICS OF THE
SCHOOL WERE READILY AVAILABLE
FOR THE TACTICAL SEARCH UNITS.
AB 2816 WILL ALLOW COMPANIES IN
THE INDUSTRY TO OFFER THESE
MAPPING SERVICES TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FIRST RESPONDERS,
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO NAVIGATE THE
CAMPUS IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY. ENHANCING
COMMUNICATION, SAVING TIME, AND
SAVING LIVES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU, AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC IN THE AUDIENCE YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD, IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE. LET ME
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? ANY
QUESTIONS? CONCERNS FOR THE
AUTHOR, FOR THE WITNESS. PLEASE,
SENATOR WILK. NO. NO MR. CHAIR,
PLEASE. MADAM VICE CHAIR. I JUST
WANT TO, WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD. I'M SURPRISED. SHOCKED,
ACTUALLY, THAT WE DON'T ALREADY
HAVE THIS IN PLACE. IT SEEMS
LIKE WE ARE LITERALLY OVERDUE,
ON ON ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THESE SAFETY MEASURES IN PLACE,
AT OUR SCHOOLS. SO I'M GRATEFUL
FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND I'M GOING TO BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE
MOMENT, MOMENT. APPRECIATE THAT,
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU. WAR
FAMILY. SO I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL, AND THEN SOMETIMES THESE
THINGS ARE QUICK. SO BACK ON
NOVEMBER 14TH OF 2017, HAD A
SCHOOL SHOOTING AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT MY KIDS HAD
ATTENDED. IT WAS IT WAS OVER IN
16 SECONDS. THE KID BUILT A
GHOST GUN, WHICH IS WHY I'VE
BEEN AGAINST GHOST GUNS, KILLED
TWO PEOPLE, WOUNDED TWO PEOPLE,
TOOK HIS OWN LIFE. AND THE FIRST
PERSON ON THE SCENE WAS A FRIEND
OF MINE WHO'S A DETECTIVE WHO
WAS DROPPING OFF HIS SON, HEARD
SHOTS AND CAME IN, BUT THE KID
WAS ALREADY DEAD. AND THESE
THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN MORE
OFTEN. I THINK, THAN LESS. LESS.
SO I AM CURIOUS, THOUGH, IF, YOU
KNOW, GREAT. IF YOU DON'T,
THAT'S FINE. SO, ASSEMBLYMAN
MATHEWS, WE HEARD A BILL FROM
HIM LAST WEEK THAT WAS VERY
SIMILAR, AND THERE WAS SOME
OPPOSITION TO HIS BILL, WHICH
I'M NOT SURE WHY. ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH HIS BILL IF YOU'RE
NOT, THEN THAT'S FINE, BECAUSE
I'M JUST CURIOUS. SURE. I'VE
HEARD THAT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS HAS SUCH A BILL, BUT I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH. I CAN CLARIFY
JUST A LITTLE BIT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE
INFORMATION THAT MIGHT BE USED
BY AN APP OR OR A WEB BASED
APPROACH MIGHT BE EXPOSED OR
OTHERWISE SHARED. SO THERE WAS
SOME PRIVACY CONCERNS. SO HOW
ARE FIRST RESPONDERS GOING TO
ACCESS THE INFORMATION ON THIS?
SURE. I WANT TO TURN TO MY
WITNESS. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THERE'S A MYRIAD OF SYSTEMS THAT
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEMS USE RIGHT
NOW. MOST OF THOSE SYSTEMS ARE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INFORMATION
SYSTEMS COMPLIANT OR CJIS
COMPLIANCE. SO WHEN THE VENDOR
GIVES THE MAPPING DATA TO THE
DISTRICT OR TO PUBLIC SAFETY, I
CALL THAT THE SECOND PILLAR OF
SECURITY, IT RESIDES WITHIN
THOSE SOFTWARE SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE PRETTY SAFE. AND THEN I
GUESS I WOULD EXPOUND UPON THAT.
THE THIRD PART WOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, ACCESSIBILITY AND
SECURITY. THERE'S NOTHING TOP
SECRET IN THIS INFORMATION. IT'S
NOT A WEB BASED APPLICATION.
IT'S MAPPING DATA. AND SO IT'S
FAR MORE IMPORTANT THAT THE
DISTRICT STAFF AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY CAN ACCESS THAT AND THE
SYSTEMS THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
COMFORTABLE USING. OKAY. GREAT.
THANK YOU. HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS I TOO ARE GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. THE
WITNESS. YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE, ASSEMBLY BILL 2816
ASSURES SAFETY FOR OUR CHILDREN
K THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH FIRST RESPONDERS WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY, WITH THE UPDATED
TECHNOLOGY, TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR CHILDREN ARE SAFE ON CAMPUS.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE
THAT OUR FIRST RESPONDER, IF
CALLED UPON, DURING SUCH A TIME
WHERE THERE'S AN ACTIVE SHOOTING
SHOOTER, UNDERSTAND THE LAYOUT
OR IS ABLE TO ONE IDENTIFY AND
DEPLOY OFFICERS AT THE
APPROPRIATE LOCATIONS SO IT
DOESN'T SO WE KNOW WHO'S ON
FIRST AND WHO'S ON SECOND. AND
THIS WHAT THIS TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS
US TO HAPPEN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AND I VOTE FOR OUR CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CHOBOQ, THANK YOU, MADAM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM 19 AB 2016 GIBSON MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN IACOBO
OBAGI CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. LIMON. WILK AYE.
WILKIE VERY GOOD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. HANSON. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, NEXT UP, I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MY NEIGHBOR AND
COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. OPPOSED? NO,
COLLEAGUE. NOT MY NEIGHBOR IN
COLLEGE. SHE WENT TO UCLA. I
COULDN'T GET INTO UCLA. ALL
RIGHT. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS. TODAY
I'M. I AM PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL 2395. THIS BILL PROVIDES
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM INCREASED FLEX ABILITY
FOR HOW IT CAN USE CONTINUING
EDUCATION FUNDS AND INCLUDES
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING HOME TO THE NATION'S
LARGEST AND MOST DIVERSE FOUR
YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
THE CSU OPERATES 23
UNIVERSITIES, 87 OFF CAMPUS
CENTERS, AND SERVES NEARLY
460,000 STUDENTS EACH YEAR,
INCLUDING CAL STATE FULLERTON,
HOME OF THE TITANS, MY HOMETOWN
IN 1971, THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION RESERVE FUND TO HELP
ADULT LEARNERS MEET WORKFORCE
NEEDS. WORKFORCE NEEDS NOT MET
BY TRADITIONAL STATE OPERATED
STATE SUPPORTED OFFERINGS. OVER
THE YEARS, THE SELF SUPPORT
PROGRAMS, FUNDED BY REVENUES
DEPOSITED AND THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION REVENUE FUND HAVE
EXPANDED. THEY NOW INCLUDE
DEGREE AND NON-DEGREE PROGRAMS,
CERTIFICATES, CREDENTIALS AND
OTHER INNOVATIVE WORKFORCE
RELATED PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. UNLIKE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
REVENUES DEPOSITED IN THE CSU'S
CONTINUING EDUCATION FUND ARE
CONSTRAINED BY DATED
REQUIREMENTS TO NARROW PURPOSES.
TECHNICAL ADVANCEMENTS, AND
HIGHER EDUCATION STRATEGIES HAVE
CHANGED SINCE THE EARLY 1970S,
AND EXISTING LAW PREVENTS THESE
FUNDS FROM BEING UTILIZED FOR
BROADER CAMPUS AND ACADEMIC USES
THAT SUPPORT WORKFORCE
PREPARATION DURING THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS BUDGET YEAR,
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE NOT BEING
REQUESTED FROM THE CSU IN THIS
BILL. RATHER, MY BILL WOULD
PROVIDE INCREASED FISCAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE CSU TO USE
CONTINUING EDUCATION RESERVE
FUND MORE EFFECTIVELY SO IT CAN
BETTER SERVE THE STUDENTS AND
DELIVER ON ITS EDUCATION AND
INSTITUTIONAL MISSION. WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WE HAVE.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY, LONG BEACH
PRESIDENT JANE CONNELLY AND
DOCTOR MADERA, SAVAGE
ASSISTANCE, VICE CHANCELLOR OF
PROFESSIONAL AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROGRAM. WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU. PRESIDENT CONNOLLY,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT
YOU POACHED MY BEST EMPLOYEE,
YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR
NEWMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I AM JANE CONNELLY,
PRESIDENT OF CAL STATE LONG
BEACH. AND I ALSO SERVE AS THE
CHAIR OF OUR CSU COMMISSION ON
PROFESSIONAL AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION, WHICH WE CALL PACE.
MANY ADULTS ARE RETURNING TO
SCHOOL SEEKING A CERTIFICATE OR
CREDENTIAL SO THEY CAN REMAIN IN
OR PROGRESS IN OR REENTER THE
WORKFORCE. AND INDUSTRIES ARE
EAGER TO PARTNER WITH THE CSU TO
TELL US WHAT THE LATEST SKILLS
AND DISPOSITIONS AND KNOWLEDGE
ARE VITAL IN THEIR INDUSTRIES.
SEGMENTS. THE CSU ENABLES
CONTINUOUS EDUCATION BY BUILDING
ON THE UNIQUE ASPECTS OF OUR
UNIVERSITY, AND EMBRACES OUR
DUAL MISSION OF SERVING OUR
INITIAL DEGREE SEEKERS, ALONG
WITH CAREER AND LIFELONG
LEARNERS AND DEGREE COMPLETERS.
THE AT THIS POINT, WE NEED TO
EXPAND OUR CSU MISSION, THE
FUTURE OF WORK, WHICH IS ALREADY
HERE, DEMANDS CONTINUOUS
UPSKILLING AND RESKILLING AND WE
SEE THIS DEMAND IN SURVEY DATA,
EXCUSE ME. SURVEY DATA FROM OUR
ALUMNI BASE. AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
ALL READ ABOUT THIS. THE
SHAKEUPS IN THE TECH INDUSTRY,
IT IS CRITICAL FOR US TO
CONSIDER THE IMPORTANCE OF A
COMPLETED DEGREE OR ADDITIONAL
CREDENTIALS FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT. BUT WE SEE THE
STUDENT POPULATION CHANGING
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL AGE
STUDENTS, WE SEE INCREASING
DEMAND AMONG ADULT LEARNERS
NEEDING TO COMPLETE DEGREES. A
POPULATION NOW OF OVER 6.6
MILLION CALIFORNIANS, OR TO GAIN
NEW SKILLS AS THEY NAVIGATE AN
EVER CHANGING AND INCREASINGLY
COMPLEX JOB MARKET. DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS AND OTHER
POST-SECONDARY CREDENTIALS ARE
MORE NECESSARY THAN EVER TO
ADDRESS STATE WORKFORCE DEMANDS.
OUR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS MUST
ADAPT TO MEET LEARNERS WHERE
THEY ARE, AND THIS MEANS WE
MORE. WE NEED MORE ONLINE HYBRID
PROGRAMS FOR OUR WORKFORCE THAT
NEEDS FLEXIBILITY TO MAINTAIN
WORK LIFE BALANCE AND PACE CAN
PROVIDE THIS FLEXIBILITY. I'LL
GIVE YOU A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
FROM MY OWN CAMPUS. CSULB HOLDS
TRUE TO ITS PURPOSE. PURPOSE TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF ALL
LEARNERS IN OUR REGION,
PARTICULARLY AS OUR ENROLLMENT
GROWS VIA MID-CAREER AND
LIFELONG LEARNERS. THE
FLEXIBILITY THIS BILL PROVIDES
WILL ALLOW US TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO MORE WORK FOR ALL OF OUR
FACULTY AS WE OPEN UP MORE
FUNDING, ACCESS TO OUR FACULTY
TO DESIGN NEW AND RELEVANT AND
IN-DEMAND PROGRAMS AND ADAPT
THEM TO AN EVER CHANGING NATURE
OF WORK AND THE JOB MARKET. OUR
BRAND DEPENDS ON OUR FACULTY. WE
WANT THEM TO DESIGN PROGRAMS
THAT THEY MAY OR MAY NOT BE
TEACHING TO ENSURE A SEAMLESS
AND SUPPORTIVE BEACH EXPERIENCE
FOR ALL LEARNERS. WE PLAN TO
INTEGRATE CURRENTLY DUPLICATED
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES,
INCLUDING STRATEGIC ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT, PLANNING, INTEGRATED
ENROLLMENT SERVICES, WHICH
INCLUDE OUTREACH OR MARKETING,
RECRUITMENT AND ADMISSION,
ACADEMIC AND CAREER ADVISING,
AND THE BASIC NEEDS PROGRAM
CRITICAL TO SO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS. AT THE MOMENT,
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE UNDER THE
CONSTRAINTS. A KEY EXAMPLE OF
HOW THIS BILL WILL HELP US
EXPAND OUR IMPACT IN OUR REGION
STARTS WITH THE GLOBAL LOGISTICS
AND SUPPLY CHAIN INDUSTRY. THIS
ONE OUT OF EIGHT JOBS IN LONG
BEACH ARE CONNECTED TO THIS.
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN CSULB, LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE, LONG BEACH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH, AND
INDUSTRY. OTHER INDUSTRY
PARTNERS HAVE CREATED A TALENT
PIPELINE THAT OPENS ACCESS TO
CAREERS IN LOGISTICS, EARLY
ACCESS TO CAREER EXPLORATION,
EXPLORATION, AND HIGH SCHOOL
BRINGS THESE PARTNERS TOGETHER
TO INTRODUCE, USE TO YOUTHS TO
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY, WHO OFTEN MATRICULATE
TO LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND
THEN TRANSFER TO CSULB OR
MATRICULATE DIRECTLY TO THE
BEACH TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION. MANY OF THESE
STUDENTS THEN ENTER OUR LOCAL
WORKFORCE, ENSURING THAT WE
RETAIN TALENT IN OUR REGION AND
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE DYNAMIC
NEEDS OF AN INDUSTRY UNDERGOING
CONTINUOUS CHANGE. THE
FLEXIBILITY AND FUNDS WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR ABILITY TO EXPAND
TALENT PIPELINES LIKE THIS, FOR
EXAMPLE TO HOSPITALITY
MANAGEMENT, HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION. IT WILL INCLUDE MORE
OF OUR FACULTY IN THE PROGRAMS
GROWTH AND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT, AND ENSURE THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF CSULB TO RESPOND
RAPIDLY TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN THIS OVER
TO A CSU ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR, MANDURAH SAVAGE, TO
DISCUSS A SYSTEM WIDE
PERSPECTIVE. DOCTOR SAVAGE,
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN. I AM AMANDA
SAVAGE, THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR PROFESSIONAL AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION. IN MY
ROLE, I PROVIDE SYSTEM OF
LEADERSHIP AND OVERARCHING
VISION AND STRATEGY. THE CURRENT
CODE RESTRICTS THE USE OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION FUNDS
SOLELY TO ACTIVITIES DIRECTLY
LINKED WITH SELF-SUPPORT
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS. HOWEVER,
ACADEMIC UNITS, DESPITE
BENEFITING FROM REVENUE SHARES,
ARE CONSTRAINED BY EXPENDITURE
LIMITS AND CANNOT ALLOCATE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT BROADER
ACADEMIC OPERATIONS SUCH AS
STUDENT SERVICES AND ACADEMIC
SUPPORT. THIS LIMITATION HAS
LIMITED OR HINDERED THE
DEVELOPMENT AND LAUNCH OF NEW
PROGRAMS. THERE IS INCREASED
COMPETITION TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
WITH THE EMERGENCE OF OUT OF
STATE ENTITIES WHO ARE
AGGRESSIVELY MARKETING THEIR
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA,
EXPANDING AND DEVELOPING DEGREES
AND CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS THROUGH
PACE, WITH A FOCUS ON PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THE STUDENTS WHERE
THEY ARE IS ESSENTIAL. RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, STRENGTHENS
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING ANNUAL
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON ALL
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES. WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
SO THAT PACE, A VITAL COMPONENT
OF CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATIONAL
ECOSYSTEM, CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING LIFELONG LEARNING
EXPERIENCES THAT PROMOTE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND PERSONAL
GROWTH FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THAT CONCLUDES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE
TODAY. SEEING NONE. ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES THE BILL, I
WILL SAY I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. AND I THINK SENATOR GLAZER
HAS DONE SOME SOME TERRIFIC WORK
ON STUDENT SUCCESS, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE GOAL, THE ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE FUNDS FOR STUDENT
RETENTION AND REENGAGING FORMER
STUDENTS AND I THINK WE BOTH
AGREE THAT'S IMPORTANT. SO I AM
EQUALLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. SENATOR CHOBOQ, JUST
ONE QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO
SAFETY GUARDS THAT THIS THAT
THESE FUNDINGS, THIS FUND
ACTUALLY IS LIMITED TO THE GOALS
THAT YOU HAVE STATED ON, ON, ON.
YES THIS, THIS THIS APPROACH IS
SUPPORTED BY ALL 23 PRESIDENTS
OF THE CSU. I'M IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH THEM. WE ALL
REALIZE THAT WE ARE BUILDING A
NEW ENTERPRISE OR AN EXPANDED
ENTERPRISE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS, AS WE WILL BE
REPORTING, AS WE ALWAYS DO. I
MEAN, WE HAVE A REPORT RIGHT NOW
THAT LISTS EVERY EXPENDITURE
WILL ADD A COLUMN, BUT THE IDEA
IS NOT TO, FOR EXAMPLE, FULFILL
SOME SHORT TERM BUDGET PROBLEM,
BUT IN FACT TO BUILD ON THE
ENTERPRISE. SO THE GUARDRAIL IS
THAT IT WILL BE PUBLIC
INFORMATION. WE CAN GET FEEDBACK
FROM OUR ACADEMIC SENATE, WE CAN
GET FEEDBACK FROM OUR STATE
AUDITORS, AND CERTAINLY FROM
OUR, INTERNAL CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AUDITORS. BUT THERE'S NO
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
SOMETHING. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
TAKE SOMETHING AWAY. YOU KNOW,
WITH EMERGENCIES, FINANCIAL
EMERGENCIES, WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS, ESPECIALLY
NOW THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD.
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THOSE SECURITY GUARDRAILS IN
PLACE FOR ACCOUNTABILITY, JUST
ENSURE THAT IT IS IT IS SPENT
THE WAY IT'S INTENDED.
ABSOLUTELY. AS WE'VE SEEN IN
MANY OTHER, ENTITIES, THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. SO WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT IN PLACE. I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A WORK GROUP
RIGHT NOW THAT, WE JOINTLY
ENJOINED TO DEVELOP THAT
FRAMEWORK WITH THE PRESIDENTS,
WITH THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICERS, WITH THE DEANS OF THE,
PACE PROGRAMS IN OUR CAMPUSES.
SO IT'S CERTAINLY A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS WE ANTICIPATE, WE
HOPE TO ANTICIPATE YOUR AYE VOTE
AND, APPLICATION. BUT THERE WILL
CERTAINLY BE A FRAMEWORK
DOCUMENT ONCE WE UNDERSTAND,
WHAT THE WISHES OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARE. AND OF COURSE,
TALKING ABOUT THE COST OF
TUITION AND THE COST OF
EDUCATION, THE OTHER COMMENT I'M
JUST GOING TO PLANT THE SEED
HERE IS HAVE WE LOOKED AT
REASSESS WHETHER OR NOT MAYBE
WE'RE OVERCHARGING OUR STUDENTS
FOR THE EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES
THEY'RE WE'RE THE CHEAPEST,
WE'RE THE CHEAPEST HIGH, HIGH
QUALITY PRODUCT ON THE BLOCK,
OUR COSTS ARE CONSTRAINED. WE
ARE IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENT, WESTERN GOVERNORS,
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY, OTHER
ENTITIES HAVE ENTERED
CALIFORNIA. SO WE CAN'T CHARGE
MORE THAN THEY DO. AND YOU KNOW,
MY UNIVERSITY CHARGES $7,000 A
YEAR FOR, FOR REGULAR TUITION.
SO CERTAINLY WE WANT THOSE COSTS
TO BE, EQUIVALENT. YOU KNOW, OUR
JOB IS TO PROVIDE ACCESS, NOT TO
MAKE MONEY AND ANYTHING ELSE. TO
BE CLEAR, I MEAN, THIS IS ABOUT
CONTINUING EDUCATION, WHICH BY
STATUTE HAS TO BE SELF-FUNDED,
RIGHT? SO, SO PART OF THE GOAL
HERE ACTUALLY IS WITH AN EYE ON
THE FISCAL CHALLENGE, MAKING
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS ON A CONTINUING BASIS,
DESPITE THE FISCAL CHALLENGE.
RIGHT. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
ACTUALLY QUITE EXCITED ABOUT
THIS. I'M A HUGE BELIEVER IN
CONTINUING EDUCATION, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S ALWAYS
THAT TENSION, ESPECIALLY IN A
CHALLENGING FISCAL ENVIRONMENT,
TO, TO PRIORITIZE. AND SO I GIVE
THE AUTHOR CREDIT. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY, AND I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR FIVE YEARS,
LONG BEFORE THE CURRENT BUDGET
SITUATION. KIND OF CAME ON A
HORIZON. I APPRECIATE THAT. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
GLAZER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE ITEM 15 AB 2395
QUIRK-SILVA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED, THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER.
I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LYMAN
WILK. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. TO
THE WITNESSES. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO TRAVELED
UP WITH THE WITNESSES, GOOD TO
SEE YOU, AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO. WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. AS YOU WERE. LAST
BUT NOT LEAST ON OUR AGENDA. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. TOTALLY
FINE. DO YOU HAVE DO YOU HAVE
WITNESSES? OKAY. WELCOME.
PLEASE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 2865, WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS LEARN AND UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTS ALCOHOL CAN HAVE ON
THEIR BODIES LONG TERM. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THAT SCHOOL
INSTRUCTION OF ALCOHOL,
NARCOTICS, AND DANGEROUS DRUGS
AND HOW IT CAN MAKE AN IMPACT ON
OUR BODIES. BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION, CURRENT
EDUCATION FALLS JUST A BIT SHORT
ON EXCESSIVE USE ON SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM HEALTH RISKS
RELATED TO ALCOHOL AND ITS
CONNECTION TO DEPRESSION, MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES, MEMORY LOSS,
BLACKOUTS AND OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES, AND ULTIMATELY
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND ADDICTION.
WE CAN SAY THAT IT'S BAD, BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO SAY WHY THIS POLICY
IS IMPORTANT AND PERSONAL TO ME.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2023, I WAS
INVOLVED IN AN ACCIDENT WHILE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE. I'M
GRATEFUL TO GOD EVERY DAY THAT
NO ONE WAS HURT AND THAT I AM
ALIVE. IT WAS A MOMENT THAT
ABSOLUTELY CHANGED MY LIFE. I
WAS TAKEN INTO CUSTODY. I SPENT
THE NIGHT IN JAIL, FACED THE
CONSEQUENCES, AND I OWNED MY
RESPONSIBILITIES. ASIDE FROM A
VERY PUBLIC FALL, I HAD TO TAKE
A VERY HARD LOOK IN THE MIRROR
ABOUT MY BEHAVIOR, MY COPING
MECHANISMS, MY MENTAL HEALTH,
AND WAYS IN WHICH I MANAGED MY
STRESS AND MY WORK, HOW I WASN'T
TAKING CARE OF MYSELF BECAUSE OF
THE DEMANDS OF EVERYDAY THINGS
THAT WE DO, AND WHAT I BELIEVED
UP UNTIL THAT POINT WAS WHAT I
NEEDED TO DO TO SUCCEED. I
STARTED A PROGRAM AND THERAPY,
AND I REALIZED THAT I KNEW VERY
LITTLE ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
ALCOHOL AND WHAT IT WAS DOING TO
MY BODY. I LEARNED ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN ADDICTION
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE, AND THE
SHAME AND STEREOTYPES ASSOCIATED
WITH BOTH. THE FIRST FEW WEEKS
OF MY RECOVERY WERE THE HARDEST.
I WAS GOING THROUGH WITHDRAWALS
AND I HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO ME. BUT I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT SYSTEM AROUND ME. MY
FAMILY, MY FRIENDS, AND MY
INCREDIBLE STAFF. I RECOGNIZE
THAT NOT ALL OF US HAVE THAT
TYPE OF SUPPORT SYSTEM, AND IN
MY PROCESS, I BEGAN TO RECALL MY
FIRST EXPERIENCES WITH ALCOHOL.
I BECAME ANGRY AT THE GUY FROM
THE LIQUOR STORE ACROSS MY HIGH
SCHOOL WHO SOLD A 14 YEAR OLD
VERSION OF MYSELF ALCOHOL SO
THAT I COULD DRINK WITH MY
FRIENDS AND PARTY AT FOOTBALL
GAMES AND DITCH SCHOOL. I GOT
ANGRY AT THE COOL UNCLES AND
COUSINS THAT FRIENDS
QUINCEANERAS WHO GAVE MY FRIENDS
AND I A SHOTS OF TEQUILA WHEN WE
WERE ONLY 13 TO 16 YEARS OF AGE.
ALCOHOL IS SO INGRAINED IN OUR
SOCIETY AND OUR CULTURE, AND IN
WAYS ON EVERY ON OUR EVERYDAY
LIFE. WE SEE IT IN MOVIES AND
POP CULTURE AND ADVERTISEMENTS,
AND YET WE ARE SO ILL INFORMED
OF ITS CONSEQUENCES TO OUR
HEALTH. ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS
OF DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION, EXCESSIVE ALCOHOL
USE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR 178,000
DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES
BETWEEN 2020. BETWEEN 2020 AND
2021, CLOSE TO 20,000 IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE OR 488 DEATHS
PER DAY, 54 IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOR THE AGE GROUP BETWEEN 0 AND
19 YEARS OF AGE, THERE WERE
ABOUT 3028 ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES. AB
2865 AIMS TO CHANGE THAT. I WISH
THAT I WOULD HAVE KNOWN IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHAT I KNOW NOW. I WOULD
HAVE MADE DIFFERENT CHOICES. I
WANT YOUNG PEOPLE TO LEARN EARLY
HOW SOMETHING THAT IS SO LEGALLY
AND EASILY ACCESSIBLE CAN DO SO
MUCH HARM. IF NOT CONSUMED WITH
MORE KNOWLEDGE AND MORE
RESPONSIBLE KẾT I AM GRATEFUL TO
EVERYONE THAT HAS REACHED OUT TO
ME, BOTH TO WISH ME WELL IN MY
RECOVERY, BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
ALSO THOSE THAT HAVE ASKED FOR
SUPPORT. THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUFFERING IN
SILENCE AND IN SHAME IN OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY AND BACK HOME.
AND I IMAGINE ACROSS THE STATE
AND ACROSS THE UNITED STATES. TO
THEM I SAY, YOU ARE NOT ALONE.
THERE IS HELP. THERE IS NO SHAME
IN SEEKING SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE. THERE IS NO SHAME IN
ADMITTING YOU HAVE LOST A HANDLE
IN YOUR CONSUMPTION. THERE IS NO
SHAME IN WANTING TO BE A BETTER
VERSION OF YOURSELF. ALL IT
TAKES IS ONE DAY AT A TIME, AND
THE SERENITY TO ACCEPT THE
THINGS THAT WE CANNOT CHANGE,
THE COURAGE TO CHANGE THE THINGS
WE CAN, AND THE WISDOM TO KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE. AB 2865 ON
ALCOHOL EDUCATION IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IS MY WAY OF CHANGING
OUR LAWS TO SAVE LIVES AND
CARING FOR THE 418 YEAR OLD
VERSION OF MYSELF WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THE SUPPORT OR KNOWLEDGE TO
KNOW ANY BETTER. AGAIN, THANK
YOU MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL
AND I REQUEST WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND YOUR CLARITY IN
MAKING YOUR STATEMENT IMPRESSIVE
. HAS ANYBODY HERE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, SEEING NO
OPPOSITION MEMBERS. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? GO AHEAD, WELL, JUST
TO JOIN IN, I KNOW GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR, TAKING A
TERRIBLY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE
AND OWNING UP TO IT AND TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE GOOD OUT
OF IT. AND I THINK THAT YOUR
WORK HERE AND THE BILL THAT
YOU'RE ADVANCING CERTAINLY MEETS
THAT TEST FOR ME. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT. BUT AGAIN, THANK YOU
FOR, SHARING YOUR STORY BECAUSE
IT HELPS A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
AND THAT, HAVE GONE THROUGH
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE?
SENATOR GONZALEZ, DO YOU WANT TO
JUST SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH? I
MEAN, I HAVE THREE KIDS TOO, AND
TO HAVE THEM UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. BUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU ARE SO
BRAVE. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AS WELL FOR ALL OF
YOUR GOOD WORK, AND AS THE MY
COLLEAGUE SAID, YOU KNOW,
TURNING SOMETHING REALLY, REALLY
TERRIBLE THAT YOU FELT, YOU
KNOW, IN YOUR LIFE TO SOMETHING
REALLY INCREDIBLE FOR SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LIMON. THANK YOU.
AND I WANT TO ECHO WHAT OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID AND ALSO IN
ADDITION TO JUST, YOU KNOW,
TURNING A REALLY DIFFICULT
SITUATION INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BENEFIT PEOPLE, IT'S A
REMINDER THAT WHAT YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH, YOU ARE NOT ALONE.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO GO
THROUGH THIS AND WHO DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO USE THEIR VOICE,
TO CREATE BETTER. AND YOU ARE
DOING THAT. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. COULD NOT AGREE MORE. SO
THANK YOU, DID WE HAVE A MOTION?
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
GLAZER, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL IF YOU. I'LL GIVE YOU THE
CHANCE TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE
ALL THE COMMENTS AND SUPPORT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I JUST I'M JUST
GRATEFUL. I THINK WE ALL, WE
HAVE A HUGE RESPONSIBILITY KẾT
TO USE OUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
TO ULTIMATELY CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND HOPEFULLY CREATE LAWS
THAT ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE
TESTIMONIES AND REALLY IMPROVE
WHAT WE DO HERE IN THE STATE.
AND HOPEFULLY THAT HAS A RIPPLE
EFFECT. I JUST WANT YOUNG
PEOPLE, AT THE END OF THE DAY TO
KNOW WHAT I DIDN'T KNOW AND TO
MAKE DECISIONS AND EVEN ADULTS,
AS WE BEGIN TO LEARN, YOU KNOW,
IN 43 YEARS OLD AND I'M JUST
BARELY LEARNING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAD ON MY
LIFE. AND SO I HOPE THAT WITH MY
TESTIMONY, WITH THIS POLICY AND
WITH ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT, WE'RE
ABLE TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES
ALONG THE WAY, RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE, MR. CHAIR.
AND YOU WERE DOING JUST THAT. SO
WITH THAT, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
21 AB 2865, WENDY CARILLO,
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
ĐÃ NEWMAN I OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LYMAN.
LIMÓN I. WILK I WILK I, THAT
MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES. WE'LL GO.
CALL, CALL THE ROLL ONCE AGAIN
FOR SENATOR CORTEZ, ONCE AGAIN
ON FILE ITEM 21, AB 2865,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED A SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. I THAT MEASURE HAS SEVEN
VOTES. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WELL DONE WITH THAT.
LET'S LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL FOR
ANY OUTSTANDING VOTES, STARTING
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
PLEASE. MADAM CONSULTANT, ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. GLASER GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE NEXT UP
IS AB 1855. MOTION IS DỰ PASS,
THE CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND
TWO NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. GLASER
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
TO TWO. IT PASSES OUT, NEXT IS
AB 2097 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN, ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND NO
NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
OCHOA BOGH. AYE. OTOBOKE. AYE.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. LEMON. LEMON. I, MEASURE
HAS SEVEN VOTES. IT IS OUT, NEXT
IS AB 2876. ALSO FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, ITEM NUMBER NINE.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LEMON.
LEMON AYE. ALSO ADDED SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
UP IS, NUMBER TEN FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JUAN CARRILLO, AB
2071. MOTION IS DUE PASSED A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR. VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN AYE.
CORTEZ ORTEZ. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. LEMON. LEMON. AYE. THAT
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO, NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 15.
OH, NO. WE I THINK DID WE GET
THAT. WE GOT THAT ONE. NO, NO WE
NEED 15 OH 15. ITEM NUMBER 15 AB
2395 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. OKAY, MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. LEMON. LEMON AYE.
WILK OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I GUESS
WAIT, I THINK, SENATOR WILKER,
YOU OFF? OKAY, OKAY. NO THAT
MOTION RUNS OUT SIX VOTES TO
ZERO, NEXT IS, ITEM NUMBER 17,
AB 2447 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA, MOTION IS DUE. PASS,
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS ONE. NO NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
GLAZER GLAZER. NO. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. LEMON. LEMON. AYE
ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
FIVE VOTES TO ONE, NEXT IS AB
2816 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON
. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. LEMON LIMON. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. THAT MAKES THAT SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT IS AB 2901
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. OCHOA BOGH. OH OKAY,
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
AND THAT MEASURE IS AT FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT IS, AB 2998
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON.
ITEM NUMBER 26. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
EYES AND NO NO'S, WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. LEMON. LEMON. AYE
THAT MEASURE THAT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. NEXT IS AB 3074, ITEM
NUMBER 27 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO, MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE. LEMON.
LEMON. AYE THAT MEASURES OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. AND I THINK
LAST IS ITEM NUMBER 28 AB 3142
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES.
SAWYER. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NO'S WITH THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LEMON.
LEMON AYE. THANK YOU, THAT
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. THAT CLOSES OUT THE ROLE
FOR THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION, THANK
YOU AGAIN TO THE SERGEANTS, TO
THE STAFF, TO THE WITNESSES, AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES. YOU.